bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
en direct du sénat pour une après midi
consacrée à la réforme territoriale
à 17 heures un discours très attendu
celui du premier ministre manuel valls
qui devrait clarifier la position du
gouvernement en matière de réforme
territoriale les sénateurs ici attendez
bien des clarifications notamment sur le
découpage des régions qui vient en
discussion au sénat à partir de ce soir
mais également sur les futurs
département combien de départements
france quelles compétences dont discours
de manuel vals très attendu ici au sénat
à 17 heures mais tout de suite je vous
propose de rejoindre l'hémicycle du
sénat où se déroule en ce moment un
homme un éloge funèbre à christian
bourquin ancien président de la région
languedoc ancien sénateur christian
bourquin qui est mort cette année il
avait succédé à georges frêche manuel
valls qui était un proche de christian
bourquin
intervient alors de cet éloge final vous
propose de l'écouter chien un dernier
combat
malgré l'affaiblissement il avait assumé
avec un courage qui forcent l'admiration
tel est l homme ses fonctions de
sénateur des pyrénées-orientales et de
président du conseil régional de
languedoc roussillon et depuis nous le
ressentons tous
christian bourquin manque terriblement
sa famille ses proches vers lesquels
vont nos pensées il manque à cette haute
assemblée et il manque à la république
c'est avec une nouvelle fois beaucoup
d'émotion que je prends la parole ici
devant vous qui furent ses collègues
avec christian bourquin nous nous
connaissions depuis de très longues
années il avait ce qu'on appelle
l'amitié sincère
celle qui fait que l'on se dit les
choses franchement
sans fioritures parfois même sans mâcher
ses mots c'est le tempérament du
rugbyman qui parlait
énergique parfois emporté mais toujours
respectueux de l'eau est ici dans cet
hémicycle nous reviennent avec force les
images du dernier hommage que nous lui
avons rendu au tournant de l'été dans sa
petite ville de millas une ville aux
allures si catalan et pour laquelle il
avait une affection sans limite
l'affection que peut avoir vous le savez
un maire pour sa commune est là sous les
platanes nous étions plusieurs milliers
une foule immense rassemblée au delà des
appartenances politiques et dans ce
matin baignée de soleil nous étions tous
donné rendez vous pour de tristes
retrouvailles triste et solidaire à la
fois ensemble nous avons pu dire tout le
respect toute la sympathie toute la
considération que nous avions pour l'élu
bien sûr mais d'abord pour l'homme
christian bourquin avait l'engagement
chevillée au corps vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président du sénat sont
entrés en politique jeune
sa détermination infaillible son
parcours exemplaire en attestent dès
l'âge de 23 ans en effet à la mairie de
montpellier le travail côtés de georges
frêche ami et mentor des premières
heures l'ingénieur se met au service de
la collectivité sans jamais ménagé son
énergie puis au fil des années l'envy de
servir plus encore la collectivité se
fait sentir il décide alors de se
consacrer entièrement à la vie publique
et sa carrière fut à son image
talentueuse brillante passionnée avec
toujours un attachement ineo terrain à
cette prise directe avec ses administrés
qu'il chérissait par dessus tout
christian bourquin et met en effet
profondément
aller à la rencontre des habitants et il
le lui rendaient bien il aimait
intensément parcourir son département
des pyrénées-orientales
cet attachement charnel à la terre lui
venait de ses origines paysannes
malgré les honneurs il était toujours
resté ce fils d'agriculteurs de saint
féliu d'amont de son département il
connaissait les moindres route les
moindres paysage en randonneurs avertis
il avait beaucoup de joie beaucoup de
plaisir à gravir les pentes du canigou à
se sentir au coeur des éléments face à
la beauté et à l'immensité apaisantes de
la nature grand marcheur tenace
opiniâtre même christian bourquin était
un homme de conviction et donc un homme
de bataille d'abord de bataille verbale
j'en ai eu quelques unes avec lui je ne
suis pas le seul ici les n'étions pas
toujours d'accord sur tout mais je garde
le souvenir d'un contradicteur
redoutable car animée de conviction
sincère ces batailles furent aussi
électorale comme d'autres il connut les
soirs de défaite les soirs aussi deux
victoires d'abord conseiller général du
canton de millas il en devient le maire
en 1995 trois ans plus tard il prend la
présidence du conseil général des
pyrénées-orientales
élu conseiller régional du
languedoc-roussillon en 2004 il accède
alors à la première vice-présidence en
2010 il assume les responsabilités de
président après le décès de georges
frêche sur l'engagement local christian
bourquin le complète d'un engagement
nationale comme député en 1997 et puis
cela est également rappelé sénateur en
2011 les contraintes parlementaire ne
l'ont jamais éloigné de cette terre du
sud où il se sentait si bien il
considérait qu'appartenir à la
représentation nationale c'était aussi
prendre soin des territoires notamment
ceux qui se sentent oubliés et christian
bourquin s'acquitter de ses
responsabilités
avec intransigeance et panache et avec
une constance qui l'honorait dans sa vie
politique comme dans sa vie personnelle
si tant est qu'il y ait une différence
christian bourquin portait en lui la
république et la catalogne la république
d'abord humaniste christian bourquin
cultiver les vertus cardinales de
lucidité de sensibilité de mérite de
détermination au service de ses
concitoyens
et bien sûr il était intransigeant sur
ce qui rassemble les républicains c'est
à dire la laïcité la catalogne toujours
fut un fervent défenseur de sa terre
catalane de son identité mais toujours
dans le respect des principes
républicains à la tête de la région
languedoc roussillon il fait vivre les
valeurs de solidarité et de laïcité qui
étaient les siennes hommes de progrès et
de projets il avait bien compris ce que
le développement économique et social de
sa région pouvait retenir de son
ouverture vers la méditerranée
catalan de coeur
républicain dans l'âme telle était
christian bourquin entier et attachant
au nom du gouvernement
et en mon nom personnel j'adresse à sa
compagne à sa famille à ses amis à ses
proches à ses collaborateurs et à ses
collègues sénateurs notamment à ceux des
groupe rdse dont il appartenait c'était
la marque de son indépendance mais aussi
aux socialistes qui restait sa famille
tout mon soutien l'écho de la voix de
christian bourquin ne ce bel accent de
la république a quitté ses murs mais le
souvenir l'affection ne nous quitteront
jamais
monsieur le premier ministre
madame et messieurs les ministres je
vous invite maintenant à partager un
moment de recueillement à la mémoire de
christian bourquin
voilà donc pour cet éloge funèbre rendu
à l'ats christian bourquin par le sénat
cet après midi ancien président de la
région languedoc proche de manuel valls
est pour ça que le premier ministre
avait tenu l être au sénat cet
après-midi pour cet éloge funèbre pour
rendre hommage à son ami christian
bourque alors place maintenant au débat
autour de la réforme territoriale avec
ce discours très attendu de manuel valls
à partir de 17h vous pourrez bien sûr le
suivre en direct sur notre antenne la
réforme territoriale qui est très
attendu évidemment par les sénateurs
mais pas que l'association des maires
ruraux de france manifesté tout à
l'heure devant la haute assemblée je
vous propose de regarder les images de
cette manifestation et puis on va
entendre le président de cette
association des maires ruraux de france
il répondait aux questions de pauline
dames
c'est une mobilisation qui le résultat
d'un ras-le-bol ça fait trop longtemps
que les territoires héros sont négligés
l'esprit de la réforme aujourd'hui vise
à supprimer les échelons de proximité
pour aller conforter des échelons urbain
supérieur et nous pensons que
on peut raisonner différemment que la
question c'est d'abord une question
d'aménagement du territoire et ensuite
une question d'organisation territoriale
voilà vanik berberian micro de de
pauline dame c'était tout à l'heure
devant le sénat claudy lebreton lui le
patron des départements de france a été
reçu par le président du sénat gérard
larcher ce matin à la présidence du
sénat lui aussi est bien il venait
défendre ces départements auprès de
gérard larcher je vous propose de
l'écouter
il faut qu'il y ait aujourd'hui un
discours de clarifications dans la
mesure où il avait annoncé le 8 avril
dans son discours d'investiture comme
premier ministre la suppression du
conseil départemental à l'horizon 2021
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses ont
changé il a exprimé le fait qu'il
fallait une révision constitutionnelle
pour supprimer les départements donc ne
parlons plus de l'après 2020 et
considérons qu'aujourd'hui il ya le
conseil départemental qui verra le jour
au mois de mars prochain et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'ils parlent
quelles compétences il entend donner au
département voilà donc claudy lebreton
ce matin à la présidence à sa sortie de
la présidence du sénat où il a rencontré
gérard larcher bruno retailleau le
patron des sénateurs ump est à mes côtés
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
donc avant ce discours très attendu ici
au sénat 2 manuel valls vous vous
attendez quoi précisément du
gouvernement cet après-midi a déclaré
fication sur quels points surtout
j'attends d'y comprendre quelque chose
parce que plus personne n'y comprend
rien écoutez cette réforme et est né
après le désert et municipales et elle
est marquée par l'improvisation et la
contradiction l'improvisation avec des
régions qui ont été tracés sur un coin
de table avec des économies proclamer
mais jamais justifié et des
contradictions puisque on est parti en
pensant conforter le département ensuite
en le supprimant et on aboutit avec
trois formes différentes de département
donc il faut vraiment remettre en
perspective cette réforme devait être
satisfait quand même puisque à priori la
moitié des départements au moins vont
être sauvés et si on en croit
ce qu'a obtenu jean michel baylet ce
qu'a dit aussi manuel valls a donc une
cinquantaine de départements devraient
être sauvés dans les zones les plus
rurales oui mais ce que nous voulons ce
n'est pas du coup par coup ce que nous
voulons c'est du sens c'est une logique
et on dit bien sûr oui à des grandes
régions mais à condition qu'elle faisait
que quelques compétences stratégiques
parce que on a mis la charrue avant les
boeufs on a commencé par les découper et
ensuite on va s'interroger sur les
compétences ensuite les départements oui
notamment pour une double solidarité
territoriale notamment pour le milieu
rural et puis sociale et puis
l'intercommunalité faut casser cette
barre de 20 mille habitants la 1000
habitants c'est trop peu en urbain c'est
beaucoup trop en montagne c'est beaucoup
trop dans l'hyper ruralité on dit que
les départements pourrait récupérer
certaines des compétences des
départements je pense au collège je
pense aux transports dans les
départements je pense aux routes est ce
que là vous seriez d'accord vous qui
êtes le président du conseil général de
la vendée dont on veut une logique vous
allez comprendre très vite si on veut de
grandes régions pourquoi leur donner les
transports scolaires les transports
scolaires dans mon département s'est
ramassé les gamins tous les kilomètres
ça sert à rien pour des grandes régions
on va éloigner un peu plus les décisions
alors que c'est dans la proximité qu'on
doit être dans l'efficacité donc je
crois que oui pour les grandes régions
sur des compétences programmatique
stratégiques des grandes infrastructures
l'économie pourquoi pas l'aménagement du
territoire mais pour les départements
des compétences de proximité il faut une
logique c'est à dire que si on fait du
coup par coup pourquoi 50 départements
et pas 60 non je crois qu'il ya un
dessin de l'ensemble je crois que parler
de la réforme c'est le nom donné par
aidé non plus des filles vivant c'est le
curseur est entre 50 et 60 ans que l'on
veut nous c'est une logique encore une
fois on demande d'abord une
décentralisation et non pas une
recentralisation ce que le gros défaut
de cette réforme c'est que pour la
première fois depuis une cinquantaine
d'années on va recentraliser comment
voulez vous faire des économies l'état
c'est le double honneur en chef et le
doublé hier en chef est en train de nous
accuser de doublonner on peut pas faire
d'économies si on ne revoit pas les
compétences au niveau territorial on
peut pas non plus faire une réforme de
l'état donc vraiment il faut remettre à
l'endroit cette réforme c'est ce qu'on
va demander c'est ce que je veux dire
tout à l'heure au premier ministre
effectivement on entendra votre discours
comme celui des autres présidents de
groupes juste sur les régions puisque
c'est le texte qui arrive en examen dès
ce soir dans l'hémicycle du sénat la
commission spéciale du sénat choisi de
faire 15 grandes régions au lieu des 12
souhaitée par le gouvernement manuel
valls visiblement est assez fermes sur
ce chiffre de 12 est ce que vous pensez
quand même que c'est encore ouvert sur
par exemple une indépendance de l'alsace
par rapport à alors je ne perdrai pas
d'indépendance de l'alsace parce que je
pense que la france n'est pas un pays
fédéral en revanche nous avons dit oui
pour que l'alsace par exemple puissent
expérimenter une forme différencier
d'organisation en amalgamant les
départements et puis la région encore
une fois je vais vous dire il n'ya pas
plus idiot qu'un nombre qu'un chiffre un
chiffre celle degré zéro de la politique
pourquoi 15-12 non l'important c'est la
logique c'est exactement comme pour
l'intercommunalité pourquoi dire on ne
veut pas en france au mieux en milieu
rural mais y compris en milieu urbain on
ne veut pas d'intercommunalité de moins
de vingt mille habitants pourquoi 20000
encore donc voilà je vraiment c'est du
sens c'est une perspective c'est ce
qu'on va demander au premier ministre on
l'attend précisément sur ce sens sur
cette remise en perspective d'une
réforme qui est dans le brouillard le
plus total très bien merci beaucoup
bruno retailleau d'être venu en direct
sur notre antenne on va maintenant se
diriger vers la tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du sénat où se trouve notre
journaliste tran huy bonjour tam binh et
voilà donc dans à 17h discours de manuel
valls et puis ensuite je crois que les
différents présidents des groupes
politiques ici au sonar vont s'exprimer
sur cette réforme territoriale très
importante pour la haute assemblée oui
effectivement manuel valls le premier
ministre va donc prendre la parole dans
une vingtaine de minutes maintenant
l'objectif de son discours et bien tout
simplement défendre la vision du
gouvernement de la réforme territoriale
une réforme pour je cite des régions
plus fortes à taille européenne avec
toutes les compétences économiques et
sur ses régions eh bien le premier
ministre entend rester ferme après lui
et bien il devrait y avoir neuf
intervenants parmi lesquels de nombreux
présidents de groupe vous l'avez dit
jacques mézard pour le groupe rdse
françois zocchetto pour les centristes
didier guillaume pour représenter les
socialistes ou encore eliane assassi qui
représentera la voix des communistes le
débat après cette déclaration est prévu
pour durer deux heures mais cela n'est
qu'un apéritif puisqu'un 21h30 aura lieu
est bien le début de l'examen en
deuxième lecture du projet de loi sur la
réforme territoriale et sur cette
fameuse carte de région et là pas moins
de vingt-quatre orateurs sont prévues en
plus du rapporteur françois noël buffet
ump et du ministre bernard cazeneuve on
l'a dit tout à l'heure et bien la
semaine dernière les sénateurs ont
proposé lors de leurs commissions
spéciales es20 leur propre vision de la
carte des régions françaises avec 15
régions avec notamment la séparation des
régions languedoc-roussillon et
midi-pyrénées et le fait d'entériner le
fait d'avoir une alsace autonome
normalement et bien manuel valls
devraient tout à l'heure s'opposer à la
vision du sénat on écoutera
effectivement le discours de manuel
valls à partir de 17h merci beaucoup tam
dit guillaume le président du groupe
socialiste et maintenant à mes côtés
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
bruno retailleau qu'était à votre place
il y à quelques instants nous le disait
il attend du premier ministre une grande
clarification autour de la vision du
gouvernement sur cette réforme
territoriale c'est aussi votre opinion
vous avez besoin de clarté possible non
mais il vient pour ça il vient pour
faire un grand discours de politique
générale sur les collectivités locales
pour indiquer la vision du gouvernement
comment entre les grandes régions
stratège qui vont orienter la politique
les fonds européens l'université les
grandes infrastructures transport et de
l'autre côté le pôle le couple
intercommunalités et communes comment
mettre en place une instance de
proximité moderniser renouveler un
nouveau conseil départemental c'est ça
l'objectif avec mehdi guillaume pourquoi
maintenant et pourquoi pas plutôt il y
est quand même beaucoup d'atermoiements
d'allers-retours autour de cette réforme
territoriale et du coup ça a suscité pas
mal d'inquiétude chez vos collègues
sénateurs y compris à l'intérieur du
groupe socialiste mais également chez
tous les élus en france l'ubs est tout
simplement parce que ni à droite ni à
gauche personne n'était prêt une grande
réforme territoriale chacun reçu
regardant peut être un peu le nombril
regardant parfois pour certains les
cartes de visite ne voulant rien bouger
ça fait 30 ans que l'on parle de
diminuer le nombre de régions eh ben ça
va être fait par ce gouvernement après
il suffit de regarder les
intercommunalités créé il y as en 1992
il faut les faire grossir mais tenir
compte des zones rurales et de montagne
là où les intercommunalités devront
rester petit de proximité et puis les
conseils d manteau que certains
voulaient supprimé nicolas sarkozy dès
fusionner avec dans les régions le
président hollande disant on va les
supprimer en cuir à autre chose nous
nous disons non c'est le rôle du
parlement le parlement pense que et les
sénateurs socialistes notamment pense
que les conseils départementaux sont
importants notamment en zone rurale
alors si on prend les choses dans
l'ordre d'abord les grandes régions ce
avec l'objet du texte est examiné à
partir de ce soir ici par le sénat le
redécoupage des régions le gouvernement
on souhaite 12 grandes régions le texte
tel qu'il est sorti et de la commission
spéciale du sénat propose 15 régions est
ce que selon vous le gouvernement est
prêt un peu d'ouverture sur le nombre de
grandes régions en france on va voir
comment se passe le débat ce qui compte
c'est l'objectif l'objectif c'est de
diminuer le nombre de régions quasiment
par deux pour faire des grandes régions
stratège après nous regardons il ya des
choses qui ne sont pas possibles par
exemple une région alsace seul ce n'est
pas possible il faut tenir compte de l'
architecture globale et finalement nous
nous rendrons contre assez rapidement
que la carte qui a été proposé il ya
quelques semaines par le président de la
république n'était pas si mauvaise que
ça contrairement à ce que certains ont
dit et que vraisemblablement à l'arrivée
avec ce qui s'est passé ici en première
lecture nous allons nous retrouver sur
une carte qui sera votée en commission
mixte paritaire par le parlement
français et qui sera une carte à 12 13
14 régions peu importe l'unité ce qui
compte c'est la trajectoire l'alsace
vous dites seul c'est pas possible alors
du coup est ce que le nord pas de calais
peut être seul je crois que c'est
l'objet d'un amendement de l'ensemble de
votre groupe socialiste qui souhaitent
scinder le nord pas calais de la
picardie ce qu'était le projet à
l'origine du programme un public mais il
ya des les sénateurs de diverses régions
qui regardent leurs propres régions et
c'est bien normal c'est le cas en
champagne ardenne c'est le cas dans le
nord ya pas de calais c'est le cas en
midi pyrénées et en languedoc roussillon
peu importe ce n'est pas ça l'objectif
l'objectif c'est d'arriver avec des
régions des régions homogènes et de
grandes régions voilà nous verrons bien
il faut laisser faire le débat le sénat
ne doit pas être les sénateurs
vont débattre pendant deux ou trois
jours et sur le droit d'option des
départements vous parliez des
départements tout à l'heure le projet de
loi sur le découpage des régions prévoit
un droit d'option des départements
c'est-à-dire qu'ils pourront glisser
d'une région à une autre en fonction
effectivement de l'approbation de la
région de sortie de la région d'accueil
jusqu'à quand ce droit d'option pour le
département pourra s'exercer il pourra
s'exercer sur la durée et notamment dans
la période transitoire qui va de 2015 à
2020 ou 2021 mais voir même après il
faut laisser cette possibilité
il faut laisser l'initiative
territoriales se faire et nous proposons
nous l'avions fait en première lecture
que par un vote simple sans majorité
sans verrou un département qui
souhaitent changer de région avec un
vote majoritaire du conseil général avec
un vote majoritaire de la région quitté
et un vote majoritaire de la région
d'accueil entre guillemets et bien des
choses se fassent je crois que c'est
comme cela voilà le verrou a été un
petit peu plus fort parce qu'il faut une
majorité des trois cinquièmes pour
sortir d'une région est entré dans une
autre j'espère que non j'espère que ce
sera une majorité simple une majorité à
50% pourquoi trois cinquièmes je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il faille avait jusque là
toujours sur les départements dit
guillaume effectivement on attend de
voir un petit peu quelle va être la
position du premier ministre de manuel
valls autour du nombre de départements
qui serait maintenue en france on parle
d'une cinquantaine de départements où
vous avez toujours vous aussi ce chiffre
non mais il ya des chiffres qui sont qui
ont été en l'air comme ça moi je pense
qu'il faut maintenir tous les conseils
dont il faut parler de conseils
départementaux et les départements 01 02
03 ça va rester je pense qu'il faut
garder quasiment tous les conseils
départementaux peut être à l'exception
des départements où les grandes
métropoles où ils pourraient être
absorbés mais ce qui compte c'est patent
beaucoup plus donc en conserver et
beaucoup plus celle dont on n'en
garderait au moins une soixantaine alors
70 80 90 ans a donc on supprime aucun
département il n'est pas question de
supprimer les départements il s'agit un
cei départementale il s'agit pas de
supprimer les conseils départementaux de
façon pure et simple il s'agit de
clarifier de transférer beaucoup de
compétences aux régions et de mettre les
conseils départementaux sur leur coeur
de métier leur coeur de cible et
solidarité humaine vis-à-vis des
citoyens et les solidarités
territoriales les avis des communes et
puis dans la période transitoire de 2015
à 2020 2021 nous verrons bien ce qu'il
adviendra est ce qu'il y aura des
fédérations l'intercommunalité est ce
qu'il y aura encore des conseillers
départementaux savez on n'est pas là
pour défendre une carte de visite une
ligne sur une carte de visite nous
sommes là pour défendre d'efficacité
territoriales seriez vous favorable à
quel transfert de compétences entre les
départements et les régions on parle des
collèges on parle des transports des
routes oui voilà et en plus l'économie
qui était évidemment essentiel
économique ce doit être les régions les
routes les transports ce doit être les
régions les collèges moi je n'y suis pas
favorable personnel nous verrons bien ce
que je pense que c'est de la proximité
et puis dans les transports il faut que
les transports scolaires restent
conseils départementaux c'est eux qui
connaissent les lignes de proximité mais
on peut aller beaucoup plus loin il faut
que les régions et des grandes
compétences alors on le voit derrière
nous au fond le voyez laisse un petit
peu caché par les mages manuel valls qui
est au milieu de cette salle des
conférences peut-être que notre caméra
va pouvoir y aller est omis de cette
salle des conférences du sénat où il
parle en ce moment avec jean-vincent
placé le patron des écologistes avec
d'autres sénateurs ump on sent peut-être
une volonté la part du gouvernement de
renault et un peu avec le sénat est ce
que les liens étaient si distendu j'en
étais pas distendues mais la volonté du
premier ministre du chef de l'état de
tenir compte du sénat dans cette
deuxième lecture et dans la première
lecture de la loi de l'organisation
territoriale c'est ça qui est très
important et le premier ministre est
très ouvert et se veut à l'écouté du
sénat c'est pour ça je vous dit laissons
faire les débats c'est à la fin du
marché vous connaissez l'histoire donc
laissant faire les débats et nous
verrons bien ce qu'il sortira dans la
nuit de jeudi à vendredi c'est amusant
vous parlez de marché mais c'est vrai
que ça ressemble un peu au grand
marchandage cette réforme territoriale
chacun campe un peu sur son département
sur sa région justement non je ne vous
ai pas parlé de régions de départements
il faut surtout éviter de parler de sa
région et de son département je voulais
dit nous ne sommes pas là pour défendre
une ligne sur une carte de visite nous
sommes là pour faire une clarification
des compétences des collectivités
locales pour être le plus dans la
proximité dans l'efficacité c'est ça qui
est important merci beaucoup didier
guillaume est effectivement pour cette
clarification on va suivre dans quelques
minutes maintenant sur un trentaine le
discours de manuel valls sur la réforme
territoriale le premier ministre on le
voit qui dans cette salle des
conférences du sénat entouré de sénateur
je ne sais pas si on peut aller jusqu'à
lui pour essayer de de voir un petit peu
ce qui se dit
pardon
hélas
la samba
soutien barcelone
voilà non c'était une discussion en foot
on a voulu s'immiscer dans une
discussion foot entre le premier
ministre et les sénateurs des différents
groupes politiques
manuel valls qui vient donc de quitter
maintenant cette salle des conférences
du sénat pour se rendre dans l'hémicycle
du sénat où on va rejoindre notre
journaliste dans la tribune de presse
dans la nuit bonjour à nouveau et dans
quelques instants donc manuel valls va
s'installer dans l'hémicycle on va
pouvoir l'écouter et ensuite les
différents présidents des groupes
politiques du sénat oui en effet alors
qu'on instant l'hémicycle derrière moi
est en train de se remplir un vraiment
petit à petit mais on l'a vu tout à
l'heure lors de l'éloge funèbre de
christian bourquin l'hémicycle est assez
plein cet après midi il va être encore
plus plein tout à l'heure pour cette
déclaration de manuel valls sur les
collectivités sur la réforme
territoriale
on sait la réforme territoriale la
nouvelle carte des régions cette réforme
également des départements et bien c'est
un sujet qui tient extrêmement à coeur
au pour les sénateurs les sénateurs le
sénat qui représente
constitutionnellement les territoires et
on se rappelle l'été dernier et bien
cette réforme avait fait l'objet d'une
très grosse contestation ici au sénat le
sénat pourtant qui était à gauche à
l'époque depuis eh bien il ya eu le
basculement du sénat à droite est en
tout cas lors de la réunion de la
commission spéciale la semaine dernière
eh bien les sénateurs n'ont pas
complètement mise à bas la carte des
régions mais ils ont tenté de faire au
moins une proposition avec une carte
avec 15 régions contrairement à ce
qu'avait décidé l'assemblée nationale en
première lecture avec une carte avec
seulement treize régions 15 régions cela
veut notamment et bien dissocier les
régions languedoc roussillon et midi
pyrénées et gardez également une alsace
autonome alors vous l'avez dit et bien
manuel valls devrait intervenir dans
quelques instants pour donner la vision
du gouvernement sur cette réforme
territoriale manuel valls qui devrait
rester ferme lui sur ce nombre de
régions c'est cette intervention de
manuel valls va être suivis de sales de
nombreux autres représentants des
différents groupes politiques du sénat
qui vont se succéder à la tribune par
milieu et bien on sait qu'il y aura de
nombreux présidents de groupe parmi
lesquels jacques mézard pour le rds eux
françois zocchetto pour les centristes
et d'idées d'idiomes pour le groupe
socialiste notamment voilà pour le
programme de cet après midi merci
beaucoup tam voilà et on entend la
sonnerie de la séance retentir les
sénateurs vont se rendent donc dans
l'hémicycle le premier ministre est en
train de s'installer pour son discours
doit sur la réforme territoriale avant
d'écouter manuel valls est pas peut-être
retour sur la manifestation qui s'est
tenue tout à l'heure devant le sénat
s'était l'association des maires ruraux
de france est bien venu faire entendre
leur voix ils ne veulent pas être
oubliés les eaux les zones rurales ne
veulent pas être oubliés dans cette
grande réforme territoriale écouter son
président au micro de pauline dames
c'est une mobilisation qui le résultat
en a ras-le-bol ça fait trop longtemps
que les territoires héros sont j'ai
l'esprit de la réforme aujourd'hui vise
à supprimer les échanges de proximité
pour aller conforter des échelons urbain
supérieur et nous pensons que
on peut raisonner différemment que la
question c'est d'abord une question
d'aménagement du territoire et ensuite
une question d'organisation territoriale
et puis claudy lebreton le président de
l'association des départements de france
et d lui reçu par gérard larcher ce
matin le président du sénat qui a
entendu les revendications des
départements on écoute à sa sortie
claudy lebreton il faut qu'il y ait
aujourd'hui un discours de
clarifications dans la mesure où il
avait annoncé le 8 avril dans son
discours d'investiture comme premier
ministre la suppression du conseil
départemental à l'horizon 2021
aujourd'hui beaucoup de choses ont
changé il a exprimé le fait qu'il
fallait une révision constitutionnelle
pour supprimer les départements donc ne
parlons plus de l'après 2020 et
considérons qu'aujourd'hui il ya le
conseil départemental qui verra le jour
au mois de mars prochain et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui il faut qu'ils parlent
quelles compétences il entend donner au
département voilà claudy lebreton ce
matin sa sortie d'un entretien avec
gérard larcher direction donc tout de
suite l'hémicycle du sénat manuel valls
débute son discours sur la réforme
territoriale at her
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
notre pays face à la mondialisation au
monde doit se réformer pour relever les
défis
de la compétitivité
et de la solidarité pour renforcer son
économie
et moderniser sa puissance publique
réformer notre pays c'est bien la
mission que m'a confiée le président de
la république mais on ne réforme jamais
seule
réforme et implique de dialoguer
d'expliquer pour que les objectifs
soient partagés par tous en tout cas par
le plus grand nombre il était important
pour moi
alors que reprennent aujourd'hui vos
travaux sur la réforme territoriale
de m'exprimer dans cet hémicycle et je
vous remercie monsieur le président
gérard larcher de cette invitation
elle me permet de vous exposer le sens
de la réforme et sa cohérence
il y a plus de 30 ans sous le nom ans
le président de la république
françois mitterrand disait la france a
eu besoin d'un pouvoir fort et
centralisé pour ce faire elle a
aujourd'hui besoin d'un pouvoir
décentralisé pour ne pas se défaire et
ces mots n'ont rien perdu de leur force
de leur pertinence la décentralisation
ce n'est pas qu'une démarche
administrative
pas uniquement un dispositif
institutionnel c'est un souffle un élan
pour l'unité de la république sa
cohésion et l'efficacité de son action
et pour être plus forte la république a
besoin de renforcer ses territoires
dès mon premier discours de politique
générale est ici devant vous j'ai fait
de la réforme territoriale une priorité
priorité pour notre pays pour répondre à
ces attentes aux défis qui se présentent
à lui le 3 juin dernier
dans sa tribune dans la presse
quotidienne régionale le président de la
république en a fixé les ambitions la
france d'aujourd'hui c'est un pays qui
en 30 ans a gagné 10 millions
d'habitants ce dynamisme démographique
est une force que nous devons prendre en
compte dans l'organisation dans
l'aménagement de notre territoire trois
quarts de la population se concentre sur
20 % de l'espace le fait métropolitain
n'est pas un fantasme des géographes
c'est la réalité quotidienne de dizaines
de millions de français la france
d'aujourd'hui c'est un pays dont les
frontières sont anciennes
entre ville et campagne s'estompe chaque
jour davantage
95% de nos citoyens de nos concitoyens
vivent dans le territoire que l'on dit
sous influence urbaine mais ces aires
urbaines se diversifient se complexifie
la france d'aujourd'hui ce sont
également deux nouvelles inégalités
territoriales et aussi des fractures
parfois anciennes qui se sont aggravées
je parcours comme vous notre pays j'en
connais la beauté et la diversité j'en
perçois aussi les angoisses les
détresses
j'ai parlé à ses habitants des zones aux
marches des grandes villes qui
s'inquiètent devant la disparition des
services publics la poste les classes
des écoles qui ferment la brigade de
gendarmerie est menacée j'ai échangé
aussi comme vous avec ces jeunes qui
doivent quitter leur village la petite
ville où ils sont nés où ils ont leurs
attaches parce qu'ils se disent ou pas
ce qu'on leur dit que leur avenir n'est
plus ici j'ai rencontré comme vous ces
ouvriers ses employés qui voient leur
usine fermer parce que l'outil de
production et restructuré délocaliser et
j'ai enfin dialoguer avec ces
agriculteurs qui malgré leurs efforts
quotidiens doutent de la pérennité de
leur exploitation tous ces témoignages
parmi bien d'autres viennent souligner
ce risque croissant d'une dualité du
territoire national dualité avec d'un
côté les grandes villes les métropoles
inséré dans la mondialisation qui
connaissent un vrai dynamisme économique
et il ne faut pas le nier même plutôt
s'en féliciter pour en saisir toutes les
opportunités qui doivent profiter à tous
le législateur en a tiré les
conséquences d'ailleurs en 2013 en
consacrant le rôle des métropoles en
affirmant aussi la solidarité qui devait
exister entre elles et leur périphérie
la dualité
c'est à l'opposé les métropoles des
territoires qu'ils se sentent à l'écart
et subissent de plein fouet les effets
de la mondialisation les conséquences de
la crise économique et social ces
territoires sont fragilisés il pense
être oubliés abandonnés par la puissance
publique ils ont le sentiment que le
lien qui les unit à la république
c'est free jour après jour ce qui est
remis en cause c'est la promesse
républicaine offrir les mêmes
opportunités que l'on vive au coeur
d'une métropole en banlieue dans une
commune périurbaine en montagne ou dans
les outre mer ces fractures
territoriales
ce sont aussi des fractures scolaires
elles se sont accrues ces quinze
dernières années les difficultés
scolaires se concentrent dans certains
établissements dans les quartiers
défavorisés mais aussi dans les
territoires ruraux nous avons donc
décidé depuis celle rentrée de relancer
l'éducation prioritaire et je salue en
passant
l'expérimentation en cours dans les
départements du cantal et des
hautes-pyrénées les élus locaux et les
services de l'éducation nationale innove
pour réorganiser le maillage scolaire
avec des moyens dégagés il développe des
dispositifs pédagogiques comme l'accueil
des moins de 3 ans ou le plus de m que 2
places c'est là aussi un bel exemple
d'intelligence collective et de
pragmatisme mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
toutes ses factures vous les connaissez
aussi bien que moi mais
apporter des réponses adaptées
nécessite une analyse fine une analyse
approfondie
c'est le premier objectif des assises
des ruralités engagé avec la ministre du
logement de l'égalité des territoires et
de leurs réalités sylvia pinel il n'y
aurait en effet rien de pire que des
réponses identiques à des situations si
diverse la réforme de l'état territorial
qui est tout aussi fondamental et
complémentaires engagée par le ministre
de l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve
poursuit aussi cet objectif un état plus
réactif qui s'adapte aux besoins des
territoires
et aux attentes des élus locaux nous
devons réaffirmer la présence et le rôle
de l'état notamment dans les
départements là où les citoyens en ont
le plus besoin dans un monde qui bouge
si vite
l'immobilisme le statu quo l'absence de
courage serait pour notre pays des choix
lourds de conséquences des territoires
sans moyens pour construire leur avenir
des élus locaux démunis face aux
attentes de nos concitoyens pierre
mauroy qui a tellement compté pour la
décentralisation avait vu juste aucune
organisation politique ne peut
s'abstraire des conditions de son époque
et le cadre dans lequel la france évolue
a été profondément bouleversé
accélération de la mondialisation
élargissement de l'union européenne
mobilité croissante des français de
nouveaux équilibres mais aussi de
nouveaux déséquilibres se dégage et
soyons lucides notre organisation
territoriale actuelle peine à faire face
à tout cela elle doit donc évoluer le
premier objectif de cette réforme c'est
de renforcer tous les territoires de
doter les plus dynamiques des
compétences nécessaires pour poursuivre
leur développement économique mais tout
en veillant à ce que les territoires
fragilisés le swanny abandonnés à leur
sort ni privé de chances de
développement et le second objectif
c'est de redonner du sens à une action
publique devenue souvent illisibles et
les doublons concerne aussi l'action de
l'état et des collectivités locales oui
la clarification est l'objectif monsieur
le président retailleau clarté
efficacité baisse de la dépense publique
proximité clarté
proximité voilà ce que nos concitoyens
attendent de leur institution sortons
des caricatures contrairement à ce que
j'ai pu lire ou entendre celle réforme
n'a pas pour but d'affaiblir les
pouvoirs locaux me remettre en cause
l'action des élus au contraire elle est
une preuve de confiance renouvelée dans
leur capacité d'agir pour l'intérêt
général et le renforcement de
l'efficacité de nos services publics
cette confiance fait l'objet d'un
consensus national au en 1982 et en 1983
il n'existait pas mais aujourd'hui il
fait l'objet d'un consensus national
cela a été porté par gaston defferre
pierre joxe jean pierre chevènement une
confiance qui grâce au président jacques
chirac et à son premier ministre jean
pierre raffarin figure désormais dans
notre constitution la république est
désormais décentralisée au même titre qu
elle est laïque indivisible démocratique
et sociale on peut regretter d'ailleurs
que depuis 2007 aucune avancée n'ait eu
lieu en matière de décentralisation est
en effet le projet de conseiller
territorial n'en est pas une ils
n'apportaient aucune réponse réelle est
utile aux enjeux de le territoire
la décentralisation c'est donc un
fondement de la france et le
renforcement de sa démocratie depuis 30
ans les politiques menées par les
communes les départements les régions
ont façonné nos paysages
moderniser les modes de transport et les
équipements elles ont renforcé la
solidarité
faciliter l'accès du plus grand nombre à
la culture aux sports à l'éducation et
plus récemment au numérique plus encore
la décentralisation a permis
d'approfondir nos démocraties locales de
renforcer le lien de proximité de
confiance qui doit exister entre les
citoyens et leurs représentants
ce mouvement doit bien sûr se poursuivre
c'est le sens des textes sur le non
cumul et nous avons eu ici même de beaux
débats mais c'est là une évolution
majeure de nos pratiques politiques et
une attente forte des français qui
veulent des élus se consacrant
pleinement à leur mandat c'est le sens
également des avancées en matière de
parité que j'ai portés devant vous mais
d'ores et déjà soyons conscients de tout
ce qui a été accompli soyons conscients
des évolutions que nous avons su mener
ensemble et soyons certains mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs qu'aucun retour
en arrière sur ces deux sujets non cumul
et parité ne sera possible c'est ma
conviction et j'en suis convaincu elle
est partagée par le plus grand
la france
la france je le rappelais est une et
indivisible
mais la vision d'une france unie forme
avec des territoires identique et
dépasser la carte administrative de la
france doit donc tenir compte des
spécificités locales et c'est du bon
sens un territoire rural par exemple ne
fait face ni aux mêmes réalités ni aux
mêmes défis qu'une métropole c'est
pourquoi je me suis engagé auprès des
élus de montagne des élus des
territoires ruraux j'y reviendrai à
adapter la réforme territoriale aux
spécificités de leur territoire et je
veux que nous soyons pragmatiques et que
nous fassions confiance aux acteurs
locaux mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
une france qui
change
nécessite que notre organisation
territoriale évoluent les états généraux
de la démocratie territoriale porter
monsieur le président par votre
prédécesseur sur une belle initiative
pour lancer un mouvement mais
reconnaissons le face aux attentes
multiples parfois contradictoires nous
avons trop longtemps hésité quant à la
direction que nous devions prendre puis
finalement nous avons fait le choix de
commencer par les métropoles madame la
ministre texte porté par votre collègue
van beirendonck au 1er janvier 10
métropoles seront créées à lyon bordeaux
toulouse nantes brest lille rouen
grenoble strasbourg et montpellier et
nice existait déjà elles auront des
compétences accrues en matière
d'aménagement d'innovation et de
développement économiques mais elles
devront aussi renforcer les solidarités
et en créer de nouvelles le rôle de la
métropole sera pleinement atteint
si elles réussissent à concilier
rayonnement sur le plan européen le plan
mondial
proximité et cohésion sociale sur leur
territoire s'agissant du grand paris il
est essentiel que la région-capitale
franchissent une nouvelle étape dès 2016
l'émergence de la métropole et le
renforcement des intercommunalités en
grande couronne permettront de renforcer
c'est un élément essentiel pour notre
pays l'attractivité et le rayonnement
international
le grand paris c'est une grande ambition
pour la france et la métropole
parisienne doit donc disposer d'un
véritable projet global le gouvernement
y travaille avec les élus locaux les
locaux avancent eux mêmes et dans le
consensus et c'est une bonne chose nous
devons adapter le dispositif législatif
aux enjeux de la première métropoles
françaises j'y suis favorable et je les
dis à la modification de l'article 12 de
la loi matt panne tant que la
simplification institutionnelle et la
solidarité territoriale demeure
l'objectif mais je n'ai pas de doute sur
le fait que nous puissions atteindre ce
but
la métropole d'aix marseille provence
doit également voir le jour en 2016 la
construction de cette grande métropole
du sud de cette porte ouverte vers la
méditerranée est un enjeu essentiel et
le gouvernement dialogue avec tous les
élus nous vous écoutons et nous écoutons
notamment le sénateur maire jean claude
gaudin pour construire le cadre
institutionnel adapté et bâtir un projet
urbain de qualité je sais combien les
habitants l'attendent et je sais combien
notre responsabilité collective cdd et
de se tenir la deuxième ville de france
je veux enfin salué le travail
exemplaire menée par le conseil général
du rhône et la future métropole de lyon
sous l'impulsion de vos collègues gérard
collomb et michel mercier la création de
cette métropole doit permettre des
simplifications
le 1er janvier 2015 et des synergies
importantes en particulier en matière
d'aménagement de logements et de
politique sociale après les métropoles
l'étape engagé depuis avril doit
permettre de renforcer les régions en
faisant notamment émerger de façon
harmonieuse
le couple régions métropole et de
clarifier les compétences des différents
niveaux de collectivités
votre assemblée examinera dès
aujourd'hui ce soir en deuxième lecture
le projet de loi sur la carte des
régions il a été voté cela n'aura
échappé à personne par une large
majorité
et ce dès la première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
cette nouvelle carte elle semblait pour
beaucoup impossible à tracer beaucoup y
ont renoncé par le passé et bien dans
quelques semaines elle sera une réalité
comme nous en sommes convenus que
monsieur le président le projet de loi
sur les compétences sera débattu à
partir du mois de décembre
il sera présenté par la ministre de la
décentralisation
madame lebranchu et le secrétaire d'état
à la réforme territoriale
monsieur vallini
la nouvelle organisation territoriale se
sont tout d'abord des territoires plus
forts capables de préparer l'avenir et
c'est la mission des régions qui devront
bénéficier de levier puissant de levier
stratégie pour préparer leur avenir et
celui de notre pays
l'avenir en matière d'éducation de
formation professionnelle et
d'orientation au service de l'autre
jeunesse l'avenir en matière de
transport et de mobilité
c'est essentiel pour la promotion d'un
modèle de développement orientée vers la
transition énergétique et écologique
l'avenir aussi en matière d'aménagement
les territoires les régions doivent
devenir les garantes d'un développement
équilibré et de l'arrêt du tribunal ont
des richesses appartenir à des régions
fortes ce sera ainsi une chance en tout
cas c'est leur défi pour les territoires
les plus fragiles
l'avenir enfin bien sûr en matière de
développement économique et
d'accompagnement les entreprises je suis
favorable à de nouveaux transferts de
compétences de l'état vers les régions
en matière de développement économique
et à l'expérimentation en matière
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi la revue
des missions de l'état engagé par
bernard cazeneuve et thierry mandon doit
nous y aider
la réorganisation de tous les
compétences que je viens d'évoquer
instaure donc aussi une nouvelle
relation entre l'état et les régions est
gelée soulignait au congrès des régions
de france elle crée la nécessité d'un
dialogue permanent sur les grandes
stratégies économiques et d'aménagement
du territoire et pour bâtir ensemble
cette nouvelle relation j'ai proposé que
le gouvernement et l'ensemble des
présidents de région se réunissent
régulièrement des régions regroupent et
c'est aussi un territoire national plus
équilibré la commission spéciale du
sénat a proposé une nouvelle carte des
régions et je me réjouis que les
sénateurs se saisissent pleinement de ce
texte j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de lire au
président larcher le gouvernement sera
très attentif à l'évolution des débats
ils sont parfois vifs je pense par
exemple à celui sur l'avenir de l'alsace
dont nous connaissons tous et dont je
connais la place dans notre histoire
nationale et dans la république
j'ai reçu encore il ya quelques jours
les parlementaires ainsi que les
présidents de la région et de deux
conseils généraux mais nous avons besoin
de clarté et mon sens la carte voté à
l'assemblée nationale à ce mairie je
vous laisse bien sûr en débattre mais en
tout état de cause douze régions
hexagonales c'est le but que nous nous
sommes donnés quel changement et quelles
réformes et à tous ceux qui disent que
cette réforme territoriale n'apporte pas
un changement je leur demande de
regarder en face en combien de temps
nous avons réussi cette réforme et quels
sont les changements que cette nouvelle
carte de région portera à notre pays
assurer le développement de notre pays
c'est renforcer
l'efficacité de l'action publique
c'est aussi veiller à sa proximité s'est
renforcé un second couple communes
intercommunalités les politiques
publiques que ce soit en matière de
politique sociale de vie quotidienne de
culture de sport doivent être élaborés
au plus près des citoyens ceux d'entre
nous qui ont été maire ou élu local
savent combien les français sont
attachés à leur commune à cette
institution des quotidiens mais aussi à
leurs élus le maire le maire c'est bien
souvent le seul visage de la république
dans une petite commune et le maire
c'est souvent le seul responsable public
dans lequel beaucoup de nos concitoyens
se reconnaissent les conseillers
municipaux et aujourd'hui les
conseillers communautaires ce sont des
milliers de femmes et d'hommes engagés
et généreux pourquoi s'interrompent
quand on parle des mères bénévoles ou
quasi bénévole pour la plupart qui
constituent le socle de notre vie
politique et puisque nous l'avons évoqué
il y a un instant à l'occasion des
obsèques de christian bourquin à millas
dans son pays catalan j'avais eu
l'occasion de rappeler devant une foule
nombreuse
combien ces élus et notamment ces mères
devaient être davantage respectés par
leurs concitoyens tant ils donnaient à
leurs citoyens
c'est aussi cela la charpente
institutionnelle de notre pays elle
évolue et le fait dans le dialogue les
propositions de loi porté par les
députés jacques pélissard président de
l'amf et christine pires bonne un
parlementaire de l'opposition une
parlementaire de la majorité sur les
communes nouvelles elles ont je le sais
votre soutient monsieur le sénateur
françois baroin vise à rendre les
communes plus fortes et elles seront
examinées à l'assemblée nationale cette
semaine et je l'espère rapidement au
sénat des communes plus forte ce sont
aussi des communes qui savent travailler
ensemble construire une intercommunalité
nous l'avons fait j'étais président
d'une intercommunalité qui s'est élargie
c'est donc une chance pour mieux gérer
pour mutualiser pour créer des projets
de territoire en somme pouvoir plus
grande ensemble l'intercommunalité c'est
aussi ce lieu où bien souvent l'intérêt
général prime où les élus dépasse les
clivages locaux ou partisans et les
mêmes qui s'invectivent et qui
s'interrompent dans un débat au sénat et
à l'assemblée sont les mêmes qui dans
leurs intercommunalités votre ensemble
des projets pour l'intérêt général et
c'est cette france qui sait travailler
pour l'intérêt général qui est attendu
par les français et non pas dans des
émissions on s'invective
nous devons approfondir le processus
intercommunale et je suis sûr que nous
pouvons tous nous mettre d'accord là
dessus et penser les politiques à
l'échelle des bassins de vie et cela sur
tout le territoire dans de nombreux
endroits
le seuil de 20 mille habitants
apparaîtra de fait comme un minimum et
sera
dans de nombreux endroits le seuil de 20
mille habitants apparaîtra de fait comme
un minimum et sera largement dépassée
dans d'autres dans d'autres jeux les 10
dans d'autres je l' ai dit écoutez il
faudra l'adapter écoutez moi et tenir
compte du nombre de communes mais aussi
de la densité de la topographie il ne
sert à rien de m'interrompt d'autant
plus que je vais vous surprendre et gelé
indiqué je les ai indiqué et je suis sûr
que même parmi ceux qui qui qui
cherchent à interrompre ils l'ont
approuvé et applaudit gelé indiqué à la
convention de l'intercommunalité à lille
est devant les élus de montagne à
chambéry nous pourrions donner aux
commissions départementales et aux
préfets de département un pouvoir de
modulation du seuil et moi je serai
attentif
je serai attentif aux propositions du
sénat sur les divulgations apporter
messieurs et mesdames les sénateurs les
périmètres des intercommunalités doivent
se rapprocher des espaces vécu c'est le
moyen le plus efficace de permettre un
égal accès aux services publics locaux
et dans un contexte de vigilance quant à
la dépense publique que vous nous
rappeler ce développement des epc y
mettra fin aux vrais millefeuille
territorial dont on ne parle pas assez
celui des treize mille 400 syndicats
intercommunaux et ses syndicats je vous
rappelle ce sont 17 milliards d'euros de
budget dont neuf en fonctionnement dans
un souci d'économie leurs noms devraient
être fortement réduits comme nous y
incite le rapport de monsieur alain
lambert et martin malvy leurs
compétences devront aussi évidemment
être transférée aux intercommunalités et
je partage l'attachement du président
didier guillaume à cette dynamique avec
l'élection des conseillers
communautaires par fléchage le même jour
et par le même vote que les conseillers
municipaux
l'intercommunalité a enfin trouvé
progressivement la légitimité
démocratique qui lui manquait cette
démocratie intercommunale nous devrons
sans doute encore l'approfondir mais il
faut sur ces questions-là du temps nous
devons aussi toujours garder à l'esprit
que la gouvernance intercommunal pour
être efficace doit reposer sur la corde
chacun et je sais que c'est l'objectif
de la proposition de loi de vos
collègues jean pierre sueur et alain
richard vous l'avez adopté la semaine
dernière ce texte doit aboutir
rapidement et sera donc inscrit à
l'ordre du jour de l'assemblée nationale
avant la fin de l'année comme je m'y
étais engagé entre deux grandes régions
stratège et le couple communes
intercommunalités il faut des échelons
intermédiaires
assurer les solidarités sociales et
territoriales
j'ai conscience et je n'ai cessé de le
dire
encore vendredi à la délégation de
présidents de conseils généraux que j'ai
reçu à matignon et je me rendrai au
congrès de l'association des
départements de france à pau dans
quelques jours le rôle des conseils
départementaux en matière de protection
des populations les plus fragiles et de
soutien aux communes est bien sûr
indispensable
j'écoutais les parlementaires les
associations d'élus et les élus des
départements les formations politiques
aussi et vous connaissez le dialogue que
j'ai eu avec jean michel baylet les
radicaux de gauche cher jacques mézard
les assemblées départementales
les assemblées départementales qui
seront désignés lors des élections des
22 et 29 mars prochains
exerceront pleinement
leurs compétences de solidarité si
importante pour nos concitoyens et je
veux saluer à ce titre l'engagement des
personnels des départements lors de
cette phase de transition je veux être
très clair
la collectivité départementale pourra
même est de rendre conforté sur ses
compétences de solidarité territoriale
et humaines par exemple en matière
d'ingénierie territoriale et d'accès aux
services au public après 2020 le paysage
territorial aura évolué les régions se
seront appropriés leurs nouvelles
compétences les intercommunalités
structurons plus encore qu'aujourd'hui
les territoires alors peut-être le cadre
départemental pourra évoluer là où il ya
des métropoles je vous ai lu cet évident
je note qu'il ya consensus sur ce point
d'autres initiatives
d'autres initiatives bienvenues cher
didier guillaume mais il y en a d'autres
dans cette assemblée voit le jour avec
des rapprochement en cours entre
conseils départementaux ou une meilleure
coordination des intercommunalités c'est
un mouvement de réformes que le
gouvernement entend construire avec les
territoires pour permettre à chacun de
trouver la forme d'organisation qui leur
convient le mieux et cela prend
nécessairement du temps l'histoire de la
construction intercommunale au fond très
récentes le montrent bien nous avons
dont cinq ans pour préparer sereinement
les évolutions pour donner aux élus de
nouvelles opportunités d'adapter les
organisations à la diversité des sueurs
des situations faisant confiance aux
initiatives locales et je compte mois
sur le parlement est en tout cas sur le
sénat sur ce sujet là pour faire avancer
les choses mais là messieurs la grandeur
de la france c'est la grandeur des
territoires il ya bien sûr la question
les institutions je viens de l'aborder
il y a également la question des moyens
là aussi j'entends vos interrogations
vos remarques
aussi je tiens le redire l'effort de
redressement de leurs comptes publics
incombe à tous et les collectivités
devront et doivent y prendre leur part
cependant cette politique de sérieux
budgétaire nous devons la mener en
maintenant nos priorités et parmi ses
priorités il y a bien sûr
l'investissement des propositions ont
été formulées par les députés dans le
cadre du projet de loi de finances je
pense par exemple à la hausse du taux du
fonds de compensation de la tva
l'investissement local c'est aussi la
contractualisation avec des territoires
et le sait que vous êtes toutes et tous
vigilants aux discussions en cours sur
les contrats de plan ils mobiliseront 12
milliards d'euros pour les transports
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
et la transition énergétique et pour que
les régions disposent des capacités à
investir
elles devront être dotés d'une fiscalité
économique dynamique et adaptés à leurs
missions les capacités financières des
territoires c'est aussi l'effort de
péréquation nous avons décidé de le
poursuivre la réforme de la dotation
globale de fonctionnement devoir
rapprocher les moyens du monde rural
avec ceux des territoires urbains et je
proposerai de confier à deux
parlementaires l'un de la majorité
l'autre de l'opposition
une mission sur ce sujet là les moyens
les territoires enfin ce sont ceux pour
l'école les mères dans leur immense
majorité se sont mobilisés pour la
réussite de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires et
grâce à eux
grâce à eux et je veux les en remercier
de nouvelles activités sont offertes aux
enfants des parlementaires de tous les
bancs
des parlementaires de tous les bancs des
élus locaux et leurs associations ont
demandé que le soutien apporté aux
communes soient poursuivis pour des
accueils périscolaires de qualité des
amendements était déposé ce matin à
l'assemblée nationale par lé groupe crc
et rdp le gouvernement avec la ministre
de l'éducation nationale les soutiendra
le fonds d'amorçage pour les rythmes
scolaires sera donc maintenue à son
niveau actuel
les parlementaires
proposent d'ajouter qu'un projet
éducatif territorial s'assure de la
qualité de la qualité des activités
mais ce dispositif devra être mise en
oeuvre avec souplesse en tenant compte
des situations locales et les services
de l'état seront mobilisés pour
accompagner les communes et comme j'ai
eu l'occasion de l'indiquer ici même
dans cet hémicycle au ministre françois
baroin je reste à la disposition des
maires de france pour avancer sur la
question et des finances locales et du
financement de ces réformes concernant
les rythmes scolaires mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
cette réforme territoriale
marquera une étape le dynamisme de le
commune de nos intercommunalités
de nos départements de nos régions doit
bénéficier d'un cadre renouvelé nous
savons bien et les français qui
soutiennent largement cette réforme le
savent aussi aussi souhaiterait conclure
sur la méthode et si vous me le
permettez sur le rôle du sénat en
partant de la constitution le sénat
examine en premier les projets relatifs
aux collectivités locales mais sur ces
sujets aussi c'est l'assemblée nationale
qui a le dernier mot si chacun joue son
rôle si chacun joue son rôle sénat
assemblée nationale
et gouvernement nous pouvons faire de
cet équilibre une chance pour la réforme
et non pas un affrontement moi je tiens
compte de ce que les élus locaux disent
je tiendrai compte
je tiendrais compte je tiendrai compte
de ce que le sénat dire et je suis sûr
que chacun doit tenir compte de la force
de sa propre majorité à l'assemblée
comme au sénat et l'état d'esprit qui
est le mien doit être l'état d'esprit
pour y arriver de chacun lors de la
première lecture du projet de loi sur
les régions une majorité a choisi de ne
pas rentrer dans le fond du texte elle
était de circonstance et de ne pas
formuler de vraies propositions
l'assemblée nationale elle s'est saisi
du projet du gouvernement et l'a amendé
de manière significative
aujourd'hui la deuxième lecture offre au
sénat la possibilité de jouer pleinement
son rôle de législateur et vous savez
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les sénateurs que le gouvernement veut
croire dans ce dialogue nous ne serons
pas d'accord sur tout mais toutes vos
propositions seront examinées et je sais
que vous avez la possibilité de faire
bouger les lignes dans l'intérêt de la
décentralisation dans l'intérêt des
collectivités locales et dans l'intérêt
des français ce que nous sommes capables
de faire ensemble les uns et les autres
je le disais en particulier dans nos
intercommunalités pour promouvoir et
développer le territoire je suis certain
que le sénat l'assemblée nationale et le
gouvernement dont peuvent le faire pour
aboutir à une réforme juste efficace et
intelligente ai-je besoin de rappeler
que les débats que nous avons ou que
nous allons reprendre traversent toutes
nos formations politiques et chacun en
tête les débats des étapes de tous les
grands textes de décentralisation depuis
1982 il y a aussi des visages familiers
qui se posaient avec la plus grande
vigilance aux grandes lois de
décentralisation de françois mitterrand
de pierre mauroy allégations de fer et
qui aujourd'hui en sont les plus ardents
défenseurs dont nous nous rendez vous
dans quelques années sur ces textes et
chacun sait que
tout ce qui a tenu
tout ce qui a perduré et c'est
considérable le doit à une raison la
réponse à l'intérêt général c'est dans
cette voie et uniquement dans cette voie
que je veux m'inscrire par delà les
convictions par delà les itinéraires par
delà les oppositions je ne doute pas que
vous serez animé par un esprit de
responsabilité et par un amour partagé
de notre pays alors avançons
proposons
réformons et moi sur les régions sur
l'intercommunalité sur les départements
sur les compétences je suis convaincu
que nous pouvons le faire et donc je
veux faire avec vous le pari de la
confiance et ce pari si nous sommes tous
à la hauteur de nos responsabilités nous
pouvons le gagner
merci
monsieur le premier ministre
dans la suite de notre dame à la parole
est maintenant aux orateurs des groupes
premier run orateurs inscrits et le
président jacques mézard vous avez la
parole monsieur le président
monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues sur le premier ministre
je tiens en premier lieu à vous
remercier au nom groupe d'avoir
participé à l'éloge que vient de rendre
le sénat à notre regretté collègue et
ami christian bourquin
le plus bel hymne hommage que nous
pouvons rendre au président bourquin
c'est en se souvenant du combat qu'il a
encore mené ici même en juillet lors des
questions d'actualité et dans sa chair
région de voter le rejet de la fusion
avec midi-pyrénées
tout ce qu'il a exprimé avec tant de
conviction et tant d'arguments
économiques géographiques historiques
nous le partageons nous savons que
montpellier toulouse sont deux capitales
régionales
construite au cours de nombreux siècles
avec beaucoup de souffrance mais aussi
l'expérience et que l'une ne saurait
effacer l'autre monsieur le premier
ministre le sénat a entendu le message
du président bourquin dans sa réunion de
la commission spéciale il y a quelques
jours et aussi le message de la quasi
unanimité de son conseil régional il
vous appartient d'entendre le message du
sénat et de restaurer le languedoc
roussillon dans sa plénitude mais et
j'ai bien entendu votre discours avec
intérêt vous nous avez dit qu'il fallait
que nous travaillons ensemble pour
améliorer ce texte
je regrette quand même qu'il y ait
quelques minutes le gouvernement ait
déposé un amendement que j'ai ici
pour revenir strictement à la carte des
régions voté par la nasse l'assemblée
nationale
cela limite cela limite quand même
considérablement la possibilité de
dialogue et de débat
réformer il n'est de gouvernement ou de
candidats la gouvernance qui n'usent
et n'abuse de ce mot dont le
dictionnaire mes chers collègues donne
une définition que nous pourrions
méditer
réforme et je cite
rétablir dans sa forme primitive une
règle qui ces corrompus
en fait les mutations technologiques
sociologiques
économiques que nos sociétés connaissent
ces dernières décennies
impose des évolutions législatives plus
rapide dans nombre de domaines nous en
sommes les premiers convaincu de la a
modifié l' architecture des
collectivités locales et les systèmes
électoraux après chaque alternance
donc tous les cinq ans il y a info c'est
pour nous une réforme n'a de sens que si
elle améliore la situation existante
est ce le cas de la réforme territoriale
que vous nous proposez
nous ne le croyons pas et chaque semaine
qui passe nous confirme dans cette
appréciation
manifestement les gouvernements
successifs ne font pas confiance à
l'intelligence territoriale
le rapport belot ne prévoyait aucunement
le conseiller territorial le rapport
raffarin krattinger ne pouvait
sérieusement être le précurseur des deux
projets de loi validé le 19 juin dernier
par le conseil des ministres depuis deux
ans et plus d'ailleurs qu'elle
salmigondis de texte mal préparée
parfois contradictoires
l'exemple malheureux du rétablissement
de la clause générale de compétence puis
de sa suppression n'était qu'une
péripétie
d'un ensemble ou personne et surtout pas
un élu local ni trouve cohérence ni
vision d'ensemble
un jour blanc un jour noir pour une
réforme tout en gris un chemin chaotique
vers des lendemains instable
je n'ai strictement rien à retrancher à
ce que je disais à cette même tribune le
3 juillet dernier nous avions raison de
considérer que ce projet de loi ne
reposait pas sur une véritable étude
d'impact n'était le produit d'aucune
concertation
donc une consultation des collectivités
régionales concernées dont plusieurs se
sont néanmoins exprimé très fortement en
opposition bien que très majoritairement
dirigées par vos proches
comment comprendre la finalité réelle de
ces projets
quand on les comparer et je les fais
dans les mois passés au discours du
président de la république avant et
après son élection et j étais
à vos déclarations ici même monsieur le
premier ministre
lorsque vous étiez ministre de
l'intérieur et que vous défendiez devant
nous le projet d'une homme je vous cite
certains continuent de croire que
moderniser la vie politique locale c'est
supprimer un échelon
un peu plus loin le département est un
échelon de proximité essentiel un
échelon républicain par excellence je
continue on améliorera l'efficacité des
politiques publiques en éloignant les
citoyens des décisions
commencez
commencer par des coupes et des régions
avant de parler des compétences des
collectivités et de leurs ressources
c'est surréaliste et pourtant c'est ce
qui se passe mais je ne crois pas qu'on
puisse impunément découper les régions
comme la france découpe et ses colonies
sur la base des ego de grands élus selon
l'arbitraire de l'exécutif petites
régions au nord grande région au sud
faut-il mes chers collègues pour
l'exemple rappelé les déclarations du
maire de tulle indiquant lors de sa
campagne sénatoriale comment il avait
obtenu du président de la république le
changement de région du limousin vers
l'aquitaine
maire de tulle peut obtenir un
changement de région pas le président de
l'agglomération d'aurillac comprendre
je vous ferai grâce les déclarations sur
le terrain de nombre de nos collègues
candidats aux élections sénatoriales
adeptes toujours du cumul des mandats et
détracteurs de votre réforme
territoriale dans le limousin par
exemple cet exemplaire mais vérité sur
le terrain n'est pas forcément vérité à
paris
une carte régionale
déconnecté des grands bassins de vie des
flux économiques démographiques
ce peut être est ce là commence le
retour des irrédentistes régionaux au
mépris de la construction damnation et
l'aggravation des inégalités
territoriales
nous avons été nombreux dans cet
hémicycle a partagé les conclusions du
rapport raffarin krattinger qui n'ont
que peu de choses en commun avec les
deux projets de loi
ce qu'a d'ailleurs confirmé
avec force notre ancien collègue
krattinger en juillet à la commission
spéciale ce rapport raffarin krattinger
andy sachs s'est redessiné la carte des
régions en huit à dix régions avec des
compétences stratégiques un nouvel
avenir au département avec un espace
adapté à l'expression démocratique de la
ruralité espace fédérateur des
intercommunalités la garantie de la
présence de l'état avec une répartition
plus claire des compétences état
collectivités un schéma obligatoire
d'accessibilité aux services publics des
territoires notamment les plus enclavées
on est loin de ses objectifs
on pouvait penser que ce projet de loi
avait pour but de trouver les économies
nécessaires au respect des critères
imposés par l'europe monsieur le
secrétaire d'état avait annoncé
rapidement de très grandes économies
aujourd'hui on nous dit qu'elles
viendront dans un avenir indéterminé en
plus vous le savez bien le meilleur
moyen de pousser les collectivités à des
économies de gestion c'est de couper
leur dotation en leur supprimant en 2010
7 6 % de leurs recettes
c'est la réalité je ne je ne dis pas que
c'est mal
notre désaccord porte autant sur la
méthode que sur le fond
et c'est d'autant plus regrettable qu'il
existe une grande majorité d'élus pour
moderniser l'organisation territoriale
autour de grands thèmes
simplification et clarification des
compétences nous sommes d'accord avec la
suppression de la clause générale de
compétence nous sommes d'accord
développement de l'intercommunalité avec
contraintes et bonifications financière
lorsqu'il y avait eu tu alisation
bonification pour la création de
communes nouvelles voilà l'avenir
diminution et suppression de nombre de
structures interstitielle les pays on
peut les supprimer beaucoup de syndicats
mixtes d'âge ans d'association
parapublic et le sur le premier ministre
la diminution des normes insupportables
pour les collectivités vous l'avez
souvent dit à juste titre mais il ne
suffit pas de le dire il faut le faire
et il y a encore de contre-exemple
nouvelles obligations de la loi allure
dans le domaine de la création des scot
une réalité les mères n'en peuvent plus
et nous l'avons vécu hors de ces
sénatoriales de recevoir sans fin des
courriers de l'état leur imposant
constamment de nouvelles contraintes
alors qu'ils ont d'abord besoin
d'assistance à leur mission
en un mot sur les territoires dits
ruraux l'expression ambigu car il est
des territoires ruraux riches et
d'autres fragile de part leur
éloignement des centres de décisions des
pôles économiques de part leur
démographie déclinante est vieillissante
ces projets de loi je le pense peut-être
que je me trompe monsieur le premier
ministre mais je crois que ces projets
de loi vont accentuer ce déséquilibre
territorial et cette fracture comment
voulez vous que ces territoires soient
entendus dans de grandes régions alors
que pour certains ils n'auront que deux
conseils régionaux sur 150 ou 200 8 vous
vous retrancher derrière la
jurisprudence du conseil constitutionnel
à tort comme vous l'avez fait pour le
binôme c'est en tout cas un traitement
injuste
que vous infligez à ces territoires et
ce ne sont pas les assises de la
ruralité qui changeront le problème
faire des états généraux de la
démocratie territoriale ou des assises
de la ruralité c'est aussi productifs
que d'enterrer les problèmes en créant
des commissions
en outre
en l'autre c'est bafouer l'expression de
sensibilités politiques diverses
pourtant consacré par le texte même de
la constitution
pour certains territoires comme celui
que je représente nous allons vivre non
une fusion mes chers collègues mais une
annexion
d'autant plus insupportable que la voix
de nos deux représentants sera étouffée
au mépris de notre histoire de la
géographie de la proximité
j'aurai le privilège de représenter le
département le plus enclavé de france
tant par rapport à paris qu'à la future
métropole régionale à 11 heures de train
et 9 heures de route aller retour de
tout cela je ne saurais vous remercier
et ne puis que vous adressez du haut de
cette tribune une protestation
solennelle ce texte est mortifère pour
le territoire qui est le mien et la
sensibilité politique à laquelle je suis
profondément liés monsieur le premier
ministre
j'ai respect et estime pour vous vous le
savez mais pour tout cela je continuerai
à combattre votre projet de loi
mais
merci
monsieur le président
la parole est maintenant
président philippe adnot pour les
sénateurs mais appartenant à aucun gros
et pour lui même
que
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
madame messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues je n'ai que cinq minutes
j'irai donc à l'essentiel
j'ai été obligé de préparer mon texte
monsieur le premier ministre sans savoir
ce que vous alliez dire
j'en avais bien une petite idée mais
sait-on jamais depuis darwin nous savons
que nous sommes le fruit de l'évolution
et que les choses peuvent changer
s'agissant des régions le sénat en son
temps a voté à l'unanimité le principe
des grandes régions soit il semble que
depuis certains aient pensé que grande
région voulait dire deux départements je
regrette que l'alsace n'est pas compris
qu'elle pouvait parfaitement réussir sa
nouvelle entité tout en étant dans une
grande région je me souviens encore des
trémolos pour nous attirer dans un grand
test qui justifiait le financement du
tgv est jusqu'à strasbourg
grande région donc ce qui veut dire
capacité de gérer les grands dossiers
les grandes infrastructures
je ne savais pas monsieur le premier
ministre que les transports scolaires
les routes départementales
la gestion des collèges faisait partie
de ces grands dossiers
rendez vous donc pour le texte sur les
compétences des départements
il nous reste à vous démontrez que vous
faites fausse route et que d'économie il
n'y en aura pas de gabegie il y en aura
sûrement de favoritisme pour les grands
groupes c'est une évidence car très
sincèrement tous les grands marchés
seront pris par les grandes entreprises
les entreprises locales dans nos
territoires n'auront plus qu'à être sous
traitantes et je ne suis pas sûr que ce
soit un objectif intéressant pour nos
pme monsieur le premier ministre il est
de bon ton de répéter réforme réforme
est ce que pour autant cette incantation
a de la valeur en médecine un bon
traitement exige un bon diagnostic
votre diagnostic et que pour régler les
problèmes budgétaires de la france il
suffit de pressurer les collectivités
locales responsables de tous les maux
peut-être que pour les régions leur
diminution sera efficace si vous arrivez
à les cantonner dans des missions qui
demandent du recul de la dimension et
l'acceptation d'un principe de la
subsidiarité
s'agissant du département ce que vous
avez proposé le transfert des routes des
collèges et des transports scolaires est
une fausse piste il s'agit là de
politique de proximité qui ne gérerait
aucun coup un cadeau oui aucun
coût en fonction des trans et aucune
économie pardon et on voit bien que ce
qui le propose non jamais généré gérer
de transport scolaire en milieu rural
j'imagine déjà
je vous le dis quoi que vous fassiez
des conférences du sénat après le
discours tout à l'heure de manuel valls
ce discours de produits premier ministre
qui était évidemment très attendu ici
par les sénateurs qui avaient besoin de
clarté sur différents points autour de
la réforme territoriale d'abord sur la
carte des régions la commission spéciale
du sénat qui a travaillé autour de cette
réforme territoriale a proposé une carte
avec 15 grandes régions manuel valls a
semblé leur fermer la porte puisqu'il a
semblé assez inflexible autour du nombre
de douze grandes régions telles que
l'elysée l'avait proposé dans le premier
dans la première mouture du projet de
loi autour du redécoupage des régions
donc douze grandes régions bien ça
signifierait que l'alsace resterait avec
la lorraine or ici il ya une volonté des
sénateurs notamment alsacien est bien
d'être autonome entre guillemets par
rapport à la lorraine donc ça c'est le
point pour les régions concernant les
départements il ya eu beaucoup
d'échangés de regard on l'a vu tout à
l'heure dans la mystique de la part des
sénateurs notamment tous ceux qui sont
conseillers généraux présidents de
conseil général n'ont pas très bien
compris exactement ce que souhaitait
finalement manuel valls le premier
ministre qui a redonné la date butoir de
2020 quand on sort des conseils
départementaux en france mais là autour
des départements et bien ça reste assez
flou enfin concernant le seuil des 20
mille habitants pour les
intercommunalités
là aussi les sénateurs sont sont très
concernés parce que souvent ils sont
maires ou conseillers municipaux ce
seuil des 20 milles a été maintenu pour
manuel valls il pourrait même être
augmenté dans les départements dans les
régions où il y aura des grandes
métropoles en revanche le premier
ministre s'est montré beaucoup plus
flexible dans les zones plus rurales où
ce seuil des 20 mille habitants
pourraient être abaissées on va
rejoindre maintenant dans la tribune de
presse tam tran huy tome vous avez
assisté dans l'hémicycle à ce discours
du premier ministre qu'elles étaient un
petit peu les réactions des sénateurs
écoutez ici il ya une ambiance assez
surchauffé dans l'hémicycle comme vous
pouvez l'entendre derrière moi alors que
le sénateur non inscrit philippe adnot
est en train de faire lui-même son
discours et manuel valls eu tout à
l'heure a été un petit peu applaudi sur
les rangs de la gauche parfois mais il a
été surtout beaucoup chahutée sur les
rangs de la droite également sur les
rangs du groupe rdse ce combat majorité
de radicaux de gauche mais généralement
traditionnellement normalement un allié
des socialistes manuel valls que l'on a
pu entendre assez offensif d'un certain
d'arriver à ses fins elle a déjà parlé
de la réussite probable de ce projet de
loi des termes qui ont d'ailleurs l'ont
fait huer par certains sénateurs il
avait écrit en revanche particulièrement
félicité de l'attitude du sénat il a
jugé que le sénat avait une attitude
plus constructive en cette deuxième
lecture rappelons que lors de la
première lecture le sénat avait tout
simplement rejeté cette carte cette fois
ci il tilman c'est une proposition de
nouvelle carte avec 15 régions c'est à
dire avec et bien le maintien de deux
différentes régions pour le languedoc
roussillon et midi pyrénées est
également donc l'alsace autonome à sa
suite on a également pu entendre et bien
le président du groupe d rds jacques
mézard qui lui a largement fustigé ce
texte entend qu'il a jugée mortifère
pour sa formation et pour son territoire
merci beaucoup terme on vous retrouve un
petit peu plus tard dans cette tribune
de presse de l'hémicycle dizaine à noter
quand même un petit mea culpa sont au
début du discours de manuel valls le
premier ministre qui a reconnu qu'il y
avait eu peut-être un peu trop
d'hésitations de la part de l'actuel
gouvernement autour de cette réforme
territoriale manuel valls qui a
également précisé à plusieurs reprises
qu'elle pourrait être le périmètre des
compétences des futurs entérite et en
entités pardon territoriales je vous
rappelle qu'un deuxième projet de loi va
être examiné par le parlement autour des
compétences des collectivités
territoriales ce sera la dernière
semaine de descendre et de décembre ici
au sénat répit après ensuite à
l'assemblée nationale concernant ses
compétences tout ce qui concerne le
transport le développement des
territoires et bien pourrait être
étendue des départements aux régions les
régions qui pourraient aussi avoir une
expérimentation qui pourrait bénéficier
des expérimentations en matière
d'accompagnement sur l'emploi voilà on
va repartir dans l'hémicycle du sénat
c'est actuellement françois zocchetto le
patron des centristes ici à la haute
assemblée qui s'exprime on les compte
plus de complexité vous avez d'ailleurs
été assez discret sur cette nouveauté de
l'été qui consisterait à scinder les
départements aux trois catégories
je vous demande sur quels critères
concrets et avec quelle faisabilité
constitutionnelle
alors même qu'il s'agissait il y a
simplement six mois de supprimer
purement et simplement les conseils
départementaux
côté économie permettez moi de vous dire
que nous sommes dans l'illusionnisme car
aucune et d'impact ne vient démontrer
que les textes que vous présentez
conduiront à des économies
alors comment à esquiver ses réformes
une fois de plus eh bien vous nous
proposez cette fois tu sais fausse cette
fausse réforme structurelle qui consiste
à faire 1re découpage des régions
ont fait croire aux français qu'en
divisant par deux le nombre d hôtels de
région en diminuant le nombre supposé
coûteux des élus on réalisera des
économies spectaculaire
c'est vrai qu'avec une carte faciles à
reproduire dans les journaux on fait
semblant de réformer tandis qu'on laisse
sous le tapis les vrais défis qui gêne
et quitte à abuser les esprits vous
n'avez pas craint d'être en plus dans la
cohérence c'est cette stupéfiante façon
de découper la réforme en deux textes
avec tout d'abord le contenant est
ensuite le contenu alors peut-être que
les experts en communication mesurer
qu'il était plus facile de vendre une
jolie carte en couleurs que de
fastidieux transfert de compétences
mais je vous dis que en donnant
l'illusion du mouvement et en commençant
par ce qu'il y a de plus à guichen nous
passons à côté de la vraie réforme
nous centristes nous sommes convaincus
qu'un minimum de rationalité ne nuit pas
à l'action publique
redécouper les régions avant de décider
ce qu'elles devront faire est un non
sens
votre démarche
votre démarche serait celle d'un
architecte qui commencera à construire
un bâtiment sans savoir ce que ses
clients veulent tant faire
avouer que les risques de déboires sont
élevés et ce faisant vous nous placer
vous l'avez d'ailleurs dit tout à
l'heure dans une alternative pénible je
le dis devant mes collègues en effet
soit nous nous rebellons contre la
méthode et votre majorité quand bien
même réduite la majorité socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale fera seul le texte
et vous en profiterez pour décrire le
sénat
une assemblée d'inénarrables
conservateur soit ni tentant de limiter
les dégâts et c'est ce que nous allons
faire en votant un texte amendé mais
alors vous voulez faire de nouveaux
complices de cette réforme à l'envers eh
bien nous allons essayer dans cet
exercice difficile à travers les débats
de surmonter l'obstacle car c'est
tactiquement sans doute bien joué pour
vous mais c'est dommage pour notre pays
car cette réforme et vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous même à la fin de votre
propos ne mérite pas un combat
caricatural et vous savez que nous
souhaitons ardemment avancer sur ce
dossier
nous en avons terriblement besoin et
puisqu'on parle de besoin
puisque nous voulons faire des économies
j'ai quelques suggestions à vous faire
pour économiser par exemple 200 millions
d'euros dès l'année prochaine
rétablissez donc la journée de carence
dans la fonction publique
une autre suggestion à plusieurs
milliards revenez aux 39 heures dans la
sphère non marchandes
une autre suggestion encore
assouplies c'est le statut de la
fonction publique territoriale
avons nous besoin d'un régime ultra
verrouillé identique à celui qui protège
un agent des impôts ou un magistrat pour
un ingénieur territorial ou pour un
gardien à un gardien de musée municipal
s'il vous plaît si vous ne pensez pas
donné de l'air aux collectivités locales
laissez le respirer
j'en reviens à notre vision de
l'architecturé territoriale
chacun connaît ici notre attachement à
la décentralisation et je réaffirme que
nous sommes favorables à une poursuite
de la réforme de nos collectivités
en dépit de ses imperfections la loi de
décembre 2010 a permis de nombreuses
avancées tout le monde le reconnaît
maintenant mais cette loi n'a jamais eu
vocation à clore le débat nous sommes
pour la faire réforme oui il faut
s'attaquer au millefeuille territorial
c'est ainsi que nous prônons une carte
des régions au nombre réduit entre 8 et
10 disposant de compétences stratégiques
et s'appuyant sur un département
profondément rénové ce modèle
le cenalt connaît bien puisque c'est
celui qui avait défendu nos colllègues
yves krattinger et jean pierre raffarin
ici et à plusieurs reprises d'ailleurs
vous avez présenté votre réforme en vous
appuyant sur leur rapport mais en
oubliant un aspect fondamental c'est que
de grandes régions ne seront efficaces
que si elles s'appuient sur un échelon
départemental à l'exception nous en
convenons des aires urbaines très dense
nous pensons également que dans un état
unitaire décentralisé un pouvoir
d'adaptation doit s'exercer au niveau
local nous militons aussi en faveur
l'adoption de lois cadres autorisant
l'exercice d'un pouvoir réglementaire
décentralisée nous pensons qu'il s'agit
d'un excellent moyen de maîtriser la
dépense publique
par exemple
essayons de décliner un principe nouveau
concernant le rsa pourquoi le rsa versé
en lozère ou en mayenne serait-il du
même montant que celui versé à paris
puisque vous nous avez dit que
l'universalité n'était pas l'uniformité
et bien essayons de réfléchir un peu
plus loin laissez donc aux conseils
départementaux
volontaires la capacité à tenir compte
de l'adaptation nécessaire
enfin on ne peut pas faire de l'économie
d'une réflexion sur le nombre de
communes et vous l'avez dit oui la
commune doit rester l'échelon de base
dans notre organisation territoriale
mais ça ne veut pas dire soit
satisfaisant de conserver des communes
de 20 30 40 habitants et parfois moins
au niveau communal comme pour les
échelons supérieurs le principe de base
doit être le même
incité les élus à proposer la
modernisation et la rationalisation de
leur collectivité en un mot faire
confiance aux élus
nous devons être ici en tant que
législateur nous devons être des
facilitateurs de ces évolutions imaginer
au niveau local une réforme territoriale
qui marche ce n'est pas ce ne sera
jamais une réforme imposée depuis paris
le mauvais des exemples que je veux
citer sans être trop long sur cet
exemple c'est la loi sur la métropole
aix marseille provence votée par le
parlement avant que l'étude d'impact a
été réalisé et ce en concertation avec
les élus locaux les communes du bouches
du rhône ont conçu un projet équivalent
à celui de l'île de france et elles
demandent ces communes à être entendu
comme le sont celles du grand paris
nous devons
apporter des solutions innovantes en
matière de fusions de communes 13 fusion
de communes ont été réalisés depuis la
loi 2010 c'est à dire 13 communes
nouvelles sont nés ce bilan est trop
modeste nous devons continuer et la
proposition de loi déposée par jacques
pélissard doit permettre aux élus de
saisir plus facilement cette opportunité
et je vous dirais qu'à l'échelon
départemental c'est la même chose dans
notre conception si les conseils
départementaux veulent fusionner nous
devons faciliter ces rapprochements par
un cadre législatif souple
vous nous proposez dans un autre domaine
de remettre à plat la carte de
l'intercommunalité
l'article 14 du projet de loi dit notre
prévoit je cite dans l'exposé des motifs
une nouvelle orientation de la
rationalisation de la carte
intercommunale
resserré autour des bassins de vie cette
notion de bassin de vie comme élément
structurant de l'intercommunalité nous y
sommes favorables
le problème c'est que votre article 14
ne s'arrête pas là il ferait voit
surtout un accroissement de la taille
minimale de 5000 à vingt mille habitants
nous avons bien entendu tout à l'heure
votre appréciation une lancée et nous
serons très vigilants car nous sommes
fermement opposés à ce seuil appliquée
partout de vingt mille habitants
là aussi j'ai envie de vous dire
universalité ne six ne signifie pas
uniformité oui à des intercommunalités
forte et spatialement cohérente non à
des rassemblements artificiel autour du
concept de vingt mille habitants
voilà quelques mots je voudrais terminer
en parlant du calendrier électoral
quelle conclusion monsieur le premier
ministre autant d'atermoiements sur un
sujet aussi important ce n'est pas
sérieux d'ailleurs je pense qu'au fond
de vous même puisque vous avez été élu
local vous savez qu'on ne peut pas gérer
des collectivités avec un calendrier qui
évolue
chaque jour pensez vous que l'on puisse
redonner confiance aux citoyens et aux
électeurs en procédant ainsi alors si
j'ai bien suivi les élections
départementales auront finalement lieu
en mars 2015 soit nous en prenons acte
mais je me permets une remarque c'est
que si nous voulons les conseils
départementaux qui fonctionnent
normalement il faut que le mandat puisse
aller à l'essai ans dès 6 ans c'est à
dire que le mandat doit aller jusqu'à
l'année 2021 il n'est pas concevable
qu'il ya une exception pour ce mandat
en venant vous exprimer devant le sénat
vous rendez hommage monsieur le premier
ministre au travail de notre assemblée
mais aussi à tout le travail qui va
s'accomplir dans les mois qui viennent
le sénat elle représentant
constitutionnel de nos collectivités
territoriales il entend pleinement jouer
ce rôle nous voulons avec la nouvelle
majorité redonner toute sa force à la
voix du sénat le sénat doit apporter à
nouveau cher collègue sa plus-value son
expertise qui s'appuie notamment par des
élus enracinés dans leur territoire et
aussi par le vote de textes qui sont
confrontés avec la vision de l'assemblée
nationale
évidemment monsieur le premier ministre
ce sénat là des élus enracinés dans leur
territoire nous avons bien compris que
vous n'en vouliez plus depuis la loi sur
le non-cumul de mandats applicable
également au sénat nous le regrettons et
nous continuerons tant que c'est encore
possible apporter notre vision des
territoires celle du sénat celle des
élus des territoires je vous remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole et
au président bruno retailleau pour le
groupe ump donner la parole monsieur le
président
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres chers collègues vous me
permettrez de commencer mon intervention
en saluant l'initiative de notre
président du sénat gérard larcher qui a
invité le premier ministre
à remettre en perspective cette réforme
merci à notre président merci aussi au
premier ministre de l'avoir acceptée
j'espère qu'à l'heure qu'il est il ne le
regrette pas d'ailleurs
je voudrais dire que cette remise en
perspective était nécessaire elle était
doublement nécessaire
nécessaires d'abord parce que tout ce
qui que nous soyons quelles que soient
les sièges où nous sommes nous sommes
désireux de remettre le sénat au coeur
de cette réforme mais nécessaire plus
encore pour sortir de la confusion car
enfin cette réforme est né dans la
panique de la praye municipal et elle
est marqué par le double sous le double
signe de l'improvisation et la
contradiction
improvisation avec une carte régionale
dessiné sur un coin de table
improvisation toujours avec des
économies proclamer sans jamais en
fournir la moindre justification
et pour cause et contradiction puisque
on est parti avec le discours du
président de la république en corrèze
qui proclamait son amour pour les
départements et je ne parle pas de
l'engagement numéro 54 pendant la
présidentielle en passant par la
suppression des départements pour
arriver désormais un département à trois
vitesses où il a logique sans compter
d'ailleurs que pendant tout ce temps là
où on discutait suppression des
départements il y avait le grand roman
brement legrand découpage de tous les
cantons de france où est cette logique
là encore
il fallait donc sortir de cette
improvisation de ses contradictions
et je pense que cette confusion était
sanctionné dans les urnes le 28
septembre dernier alors est-ce à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on ne doit rien faire est
ce à dire qu'aujourd'hui la nouvelle
majorité sénatoriale
doit se présenter devant vous
complètement bloquée dans une posture
pavlovienne de l'opposition ça n'est pas
notre état d'esprit
nous voulons que le sénat puisse
imprimer sa marque
mais pas à n'importe quelle condition
il ya deux conditions
la première c'est que nous ne nous
contenterons pas de parole
les amendements que j'ai vu notamment
sur la carte on produit sur moi le même
effet qui l'on tue sur le président
mézard
je vous ai entendu parler
de volonté de dialogue
vous ne souhaitez pas la confrontation
mais si c'est simplement pour entendre
le sénat débattre si c'est simplement
pour ne retenir aucun de nos amendements
vous aurez un sénat de combat monsieur
le premier ministre
croyez moi
ce que nous voulons ce que nous voulons
la feuille de route que nous voulons
c'est le rapport krattinger raffarin
raffarin crac âgées pas à la découpe
dans toute sa logique dans toutes ses
conséquences
la deuxième condition si la 2ème des
conditions de l'ouverture des sénateurs
c'est que vous acceptiez de donner non
seulement du sens mais de redonner une
vision vous avez commencé à le faire
mais imparfaitement je vous dirai
pourquoi tout à l'heure à cette réforme
et je pense qu'il va falloir trancher
pas seulement dans le discours mais dans
les actes et dans le texte 3
contradiction fondamentale
la première des contradictions
recentralisation ou décentralisation
un détour rapide par l'histoire de
france puisque
vous nous en avait parlé
la france c'est l'obsession de l'unité
l'unité capétienne l'unité impérial
l'unité la république oui la république
une et indivisible
mais au fil du temps mais au fil du
temps on s'est aperçu que
l'unité nationale ne pouvait pas aller
sans une forme de respiration
territoriales ce sont les provinces sous
l'ancien régime les communes les
départements
sous la république c'est cet effort
permanent de synthèse entre l'unité et
la diversité et cette perspective
historique monsieur le premier ministre
mes chers collègues cette perspective
historique
multiséculaire à donner une vision
politique
pas seulement depuis 30 ans dès le 19e
siècle l'élu grande loi de libertés
communales les grands de loi de liberté
départementale et puis bien sûr le
général de gaulle sa tentative de
régionalisation les régions puissance de
demain puissance économique de demain et
puis vous avez cité bien sûr françois
mitterrand
mais ce que vous nous proposez jusqu'à
présent avant votre discours mais je
veux savoir si c'est un virage un énième
virage ou une vraie inflexion ce que
vous nous proposez c'est tout l'inversé
c'est une rupture c'est un recul le
texte que nous avons pour le moment est
un texte de recentralisation
recentralisation dans la méthode puisque
la carte a été dessinée non pas avec les
provinciaux ile-de-france ne bougeait
pas elle a été dessinée avec les féodaux
vous le savez bien une carte qui était
dessiné avant même de réfléchir aux
compétences et c'était une grave erreur
c'était une grave erreur parce que vous
avez pris le risque d'ouvrir la boîte de
pandore vous avez pris le risque de
déconnecter les communautés
d'appartenance tourner vers les
héritages historiques plutôt que les
communautés de projets les communauté de
destin tendue vers l'avenir
tendue vers les projets vous avez au
final renforcer le communautarisme
territoriales monsieur le premier
ministre recentralisation dans la forme
recentralisation aussi dans le fond vous
avez même juxtaposés
auprès du jacobinisme parisien vous avez
juxtaposés un nouveau jacobinisme
régionales
car enfin des grands région qui absorbe
toutes les compétences y compris
proximité des départements des schémas
prescriptif qu'il s'impose sur toutes
les autres collectivités en cascade
c'est aussi une forme de
recentralisation et quand j'entends
voyez quand j'entends chers collègues le
président de l'aef
déclaré dans un journal quotidien
régional qui la honte à chaque fois
qu'il intervient avant le préfet de
région je me dis qu'on n'est la france
n'est pas un pays de tradition fédéral
et je n'oppose aimons vous proposera
toujours à ce que derrière se
régionalise plus ou moins assumée on
veut que des membres et le pays non la
république française est une et
indivisible
nous sommes une communauté nationale et
les grandes régions nous le voulons bien
mais à la condition que les compétences
soient justement partagé parce que sinon
nous ferons des mammouths
recentralisation aussi vous avez dit
tout à l'heure dans vos discours que au
moment où vous parliez vous n'avez même
pas d'ailleurs parlé encore des
départements vous avez parlé nous
voulons renforcer le rôle des de l'état
dans les départements votre remise
intérieure avait indiqué aussi dans un
quotidien du soir qu'il voulait il
souhaitait renforcer le rôle des préfets
dans les départements recentralisation
recentralisation aussi pour la première
fois vous avez ouvert une porte nous la
saisirons sur le deuxième texte en
parler avant loi en parlant de
l'économie mais jusqu'à présent vous ne
remettez en cause aucun des grands
doublant qu'il y à un niveau de la
région et au niveau du département je
pouvais je pourrais vous citer une liste
sur les aides à la pierre le logement
l'économie l'emploi l'eau etc ou
franchement l'état et le double nre en
chef
nous sommes stupéfaits qu'aujourd'hui le
double double honneur en chef reproche
finalement aux collectivités de
doublonner il faut d'abord mettre mes
chers collègues un peu d'ordre dans les
compétences de l'état
et monsieur le premier ministre
c'est cette incapacité à penser dans le
même mouvement jusqu'à présent la
réforme territoriale et la réforme de
l'état qui vous rend incapable de
produire le moindre euro d'économie
globalement et qui vous obstruent le
chemin pour une véritable réforme de
l'état nous vous proposerons des là dès
le deuxième texte non seulement une
répartition adapté aux compétences entre
les régions les départements les
communes et les intercommunalités mais
nous souhaitons en même temps avoir une
vision claire des compétences de l'état
qui pourrait être transféré pour que on
est aussi un texte de décentralisation
qui soit conforme au grand mouvement de
décentralisation que notre pays connaît
et vous l'avez rappelé depuis plusieurs
dizaines d'années la mena avait cette
phrase superbe d'ailleurs indiqué que la
centralisation c'est toujours
l'apoplexie au centre et la paix et la
paralysie pardon à la périphérie je
crois que on est au coeur de ce débat
donc la décentralisation plutôt que la
recentralisation mais aussi la
préférence pour la proximité plutôt que
la préférence pour l'éloignement parce
que la réforme telle que vous la portez
depuis des mois et des mois c'est quoi
ce sont des grandes régions avec
l'effacement des départements et ce sont
des grandes intercommunalités avec
l'affaiblissement après demain ou demain
même des communes
ça ne peut pas marcher cela ne peut pas
marcher parce que ça correspondrait à
une forme de bureaucratisation de la
france avoir des grandes administrations
régionales qui concentrerait toutes les
administrations départementales
puisqu'ils auraient plus département
alors vous feriez des administrations
régionales de milliers de milliers de
fonctionnaires d'agents territoriaux
c'est parce que nous souhaitons et en
plus c'est déterritorialisation ne
correspond pas aux remèdes qu'il faut
apporter aux trois grandes frise
française quelles sont ces trois grandes
crises français la première la
démocratie
la démocratie nationale fonctionne mal
les français n'ont plus confiance
chers collègues en leurs élus nationaux
ils gardent un lien de conscience de
confiance avec les élus locaux
cette réforme doit aussi avoir un visage
humain et vous avez oublié la dimension
humaine dans cette réforme pourquoi
parce que il y à une loi humaine qui
veut qu'une institution proche soit une
institution et mais une institution
lointaine soit une institution dont on
se méfie tout simplement la démocratie
nationale se reconstruira par la
démocratie locale ce n'est pas en
affaiblissant ses liens
entre les citoyens
et leurs élus que vous parviendrez à
revigorer la démocratie nationale c'est
la grande leçon des grecs certes leur
démocratie elle était naissante elle
n'était pas parfaite mais elle est née
dans la cité dans un espace humain
première des crises française l'autre
des crises française aussi la fracture
territoriale
je suis heureux que vous en ayez parler
je suis un électeur de christophe
guilluy le problème aujourd'hui c'est
vous avez des métropoles bien sûr elles
sont vingt importante bien sûr on a
souhaité les conforter qui sont en prise
avec la mondialisation
et puis vous avez une france
périphérique la française oublier la
france d un vivier des invisibles la
france et fragilité sociale cas
l'impression d'être abandonné et bien si
vous n'avez plus de départements qui
assure la cohésion territoriale
cette france là vous renforcerez son
sentiment d'abandon et ne nous dit pas
que l'on il faut encore attendre cinq
ans pour déterminer l'avenir du
département si vous nous dites dans cinq
ans on verra ce sera trop tard vous ne
pouvez pas susciter temps d'instabilité
déjà la baisse des dotations c'est une
instabilité
fondamentale
et ça n'est pas mes chers collègues
seulement 11 milliards ce sera en cumul
entre 2013 fin 2013 et la fin 2017 - 28
milliards d'euros par rapport au niveau
des dotations de la fin de 2013 ce sera
une ponction terrible sur
l'investissement la fracture
territoriale bien sûr les départements
là aussi sont un remède et enfin la
troisième des crises sur laquelle je
veux insister c'est l'économie j'en ai
parlé avec la baisse probable des
investissements mais c'est une fausse
conception de la modernité et de la
mondialisation
de penser et surtout d'assimiler la
puissance à la taille la masse à
l'agilité si vous donnez aux régions
toutes les compétences si vous donnez
aux régions un des orateurs précédents
on a parlé la compétence de transport
scolaire mais c'est absolument
incohérent si vous voulez agrandir les
périmètres relevé l'horizon donner aux
nouvelles grandes régions des
compétences programmatique et seulement
quelques compétences stratégiques alors
alors
voilà on interrompt quelques instants
cette séance avec ce discours de bruno
retailleau après le discours du premier
ministre sur la réforme territoriale on
va écouter en direct de cette salle des
conférences du sénat le ministre de
l'intérieur bernard cazeneuve il vient
s'exprimer sur l' enquête autour de la
mort de rémy ferait son écoute ambition
que la mort de rémy frais cet été
occasionnés par l'utilisation de
grenades dans le cas d'une opération de
maintien de l'ordre j'ai indiqué cet
après midi à l'assemblée nationale est
depuis le début de cette affaire que je
souhaitais que toute la lumière soit
faite que nous devions la transparence à
la famille et je souhaite que nous
allions au bout de cette démarche c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai décidé
compte tenu des éléments qui ont été
communiqués par le procureur de la
république et quand bien même l'enquète
qui a été engagée ne témoignera la fin
d'aucune faute d'engager dès aujourd'hui
une inspection générale de l'inspection
générale de la police nationale et de
l'inspection générale de la gendarmerie
destinée à déterminer les conditions
d'utilisation de ces projectiles dans le
cadre d'opérations de maintien de
l'ordre
sans attendre les résultats de cette
enquête dont j'ai souhaité qu'il ne soit
communiquée sous 15 jours et décidé
aujourd'hui de suspendre l'utilisation
de ces grenades offensives jusqu'à ce
que les conclusions de cette enquête ne
soit transmise
sandra pour
moi je souhaite depuis le début de cette
affaire encore une fois que la vérité
soit pleine et entière pour la famille
n'est pas respect pour la mémoire de ce
jeune homme qui a perdu la vie à civens
dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche il ya
donc une enquête judiciaire qui se
poursuit elle n'a pas encore fait
connaître ses conclusions il ya des
juges qui vont poursuivre cette enquête
qui vont être désignés et moi je
souhaite encore une fois que toute la
vérité soit faite et le ministère de
l'intérieur contribuera à faire la
vérité parce que c'est un devoir moral
parce qu'on doit cette vérité à la
famille et aux proches de rémy fraysse
et c'est aux termes de l' enquête que
nous serons si des fautes ont été
commises ou pas mais sans attendre
encore une fois que l' enquête donne ses
résultats j'ai souhaité qu'il y ait une
inspection générale de la police
nationale et une inspection générale de
la gendarmerie nationale qui commencera
dès demain et qui me donnera ses
conclusions sous 15 jours et dans
l'attenté des conclusions de cette
enquête j'ai demandé à ce que l'on
suspende
l'utilisation de ces grenades offensives
vente
et nous verrons à ce moment-là qu'est ce
que dira le juge ces sujets se doivent
se traiter avec la plus grande rigueur
et la vérité implique aussi de la
maîtrise et du sang froid il y à une
enquête judiciaire qui est en cours
cette enquête judiciaire encore une fois
fera connaître ses conclusions elle
restituera la totalité des faits et leur
enchaînement et au terme des conclusions
de cette enquête judiciaire d'autres
dispositions pour cette reprise
mais encore une fois aujourd'hui
je veux que le principe de précaution
s'applique et je souhaite qu'il y ait
une enquête qui me communiquent et tous
les éléments concernant les conditions
d'utilisation de ces grenades qui sont
utilisés dans la police nationale et
dans la gendarmerie nationale depuis 50
ans sans qu'à aucun moment il y eu
d'incident mais encore une fois j'ai
pris des engagements et je les respecte
et je les respecte parce que nous devons
encore cela à la mémoire de ce jeune de
ce jeune homme qui a perdu la vie à
sillas dans la nuit de samedi à dimanche
nous le devons en raison de ce qu'est la
grande souffrance de ses proches de ses
parents et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai décidé de prendre ses dispositions
immédiates
souci d'apaisement également non mais ça
c'est un autre sujet nous sommes encore
une fois dans non nous sommes dans un
état de droit le premier ministre a
rappelé les choses cet après midi et il
les a rappelé de façon extrêmement
précise et rigoureuse nous sommes sur un
chantier qui n'est pas un chantier
d'état qui est un chantier réalisé sous
maîtrise d'ouvragé d'une collectivité
territoriale
après que l'ensemble des procédures en
dhr ont été respectées dans un état de
droit il est toujours possible de
manifester et de s'opposer et il est du
devoir de l'état et notamment du devoir
du ministère de l'intérieur de faire en
sorte à tout moment que les
manifestations puissent se tenir dans la
sécurité le respect de la sécurité de
ceux qui manifestent mais dans le même
temps il ya eu des violences à
l'occasion des manifestations des
dernières semaines je vais là aussi
rappelé les choses parce que chacun doit
être envoyé à sa responsabilité il ait
eu 56 policiers et gendarmes qui ont été
blessés au cours des dernières semaines
depuis le début du mois de septembre
cinquante six gendarmes et policiers
blessés ils ont eux aussi été victimes
de violences avec l'utilisation de
cocktails molotov de diverses
l'hiver projectiles qui les ont blessés
il ya eu des procédures judiciaires
engagées en raison de ces violences 80
une procédure judiciaire donc entre 9 et
est induit par ces violences dont les
forces de l'ordre avaient été les
victimes et 33 procédure judiciaire en
raison de grèves de dégradations de
biens publics encore une fois si l'on
veut que la violence cesse dans la
république il faut commencer chacun dans
nos responsabilités a rappelé que sont
les règles de droit et veillez à ce
qu'elle soit en toutes circonstances
respecter je suis dans ma responsabilité
de ministre de l'intérieur soucieux
avant tout de l'apaisement parce que
lorsqu'il n'ya pas l'apaisement lorsqu
il y à des tensions lorsqu'il ya des
violences il y à un engrenage et cet
engrenage peut conduire au drame que
l'on sait et par conséquent je veux
aussi dire dans les circonstances
particulières que nous traversons la
confiance dans les forces de l'ordre
sont tous les jours exposés qu'ils
s'exposent non seulement sur le théâtre
des tensions lorsqu'il ya des
manifestations mais tous les jours face
à une société de violence vous leur vie
se trouve exposé et il y a chaque année
des policiers des gendarmes qui perdent
leur vie pour assurer la sécurité
des français et qui tous les jours aussi
se trouve atteints dans leur chair dans
leur honneur parce qu'ils sont insultés
parce que le respect n'est pas toujours
la règle avec les forces de l'ordre donc
sinon une société de respect s'ils ont
eu une société d'apaisement il faut que
chacun encore une fois fasse attention
aux propos qu'il tient et joue
l'apaisement
voilà donc pour cette déclaration de
bernard cazeneuve dans cette salle des
conférences du sénat après les premiers
éléments de l'enquêté sur la mort du
manifestant rémy fraysse autour du
barrage de sivens on va repartir tout de
suite autour de la réforme territoriale
cette discussion cet après midi au sénat
c'est actuellement le président du
groupe socialiste didier guillaume qui
s'exprime on les écoute mais il faut une
réforme
tel que le gouvernement la présente est
tel que j'espère le parlement s'en
saisira une réforme pour rendre plus
utile les collectivités territoriales
car enfin est-ce que cela marche si bien
que cela toutes nos collectivités
locales j'entends depuis des années des
années les présidents de conseils
généraux qui nous dit mais l'état ne
paie pas ses dettes le rsa la paix à la
pch depuis 2004 c'est une catastrophe
j'entends les présidents de conseils
régionaux qui nous disent doivent en
plus d'autonomie fiscale et financière
du tout nous dirons que de dotation
c'est la réalité et j'entends les maires
de nos communes et j'ai fait la campagne
sénatoriale
ces mères qui nous disent nous n'avons
plus les moyens d'investir parce que
l'état nous sert trop le kit y voilà la
réalité est bien par rapport à cela
c'est pas depuis six mois un an ou deux
ans c'est depuis des années alors
essayons d'avancer ensemble pour faire
en sorte que les régions retrouve de
l'oxygène que les départements arrive à
avoir une vraie responsabilité et que
les communes puissent enfin à nouveau
investir alors pour réussir la réforme
oui j'ose le dire ici à cette tribune il
ne faut pas mettre en cause des élus les
élus sont les hussards de la république
les élus sont là tous les jours dans les
petites communes comme dans les
départements dans les régions pour
rendre les services pour répondre
et chaque fois que l'on mettra les élus
en cause on attaquera la république que
je sois à la gauche ou la droite les
élus nous devons toujours les soutenir
nous devons toujours les défendre parce
que ce sont eux qui font vivre le
service public dans notre territoire
mais il ne faut pas céder non plus au
conservatisme parce qu'il faudra avancer
nous ne sommes pas des conservateurs il
y en a pas dans cette assemblée il n'y a
que des sénateurs et des sénatrices qui
veulent avancer et qui veulent bouger et
enfin mes chers collègues là aussi nous
nous retrouvons toutes et tous
n'opposons pas nous posons jamais
l'urbain et le rural
n'opposons pas les villes et les
campagnes
disons que la ruralité est une chance
pour notre pays la ruralité c'est un
joyau dans la ruralité de l'activité
économique de la culture de l'artisanat
du tourisme oui prenons en compte cette
réalité la ruralité est une chance pour
d'autres pays comme les villes comme les
densité urbaine arts sont une propre
pays faisons-le et avancer ensemble
il faut donc faire confiance il faut
donc faire confiance aux territoires
c'est par les territoires elle arrive
que la réforme s'occupera à trois
conditions de clarifier les compétences
mais le premier ministre lui a proposé
de clarifier les structures parce qu'on
voit bien qu'elles doivent avancer et de
clarifier les finances parce qu'on voit
bien qu'on a souvent du mal à y arriver
et nous partons notre groupe sur des
principes fondamentaux ces principes
fondamentaux sont assez claires le
premier c'est la solidarité oui la
solidarité entre les citoyens et la
solidarité des territoires celle là elle
est indispensable il est ensuite la
proximité et vous avez eu raison les uns
et les autres de dire que nos gens pu
perdre la proximité si d'autres projets
avaient vu le jour j'ai entendu ce qui
vient de nous dire le premier ministre
la proximité sera préservé elle est
indispensable pour que nos concitoyens
retrouve les chemins de la république là
ils ne croient plus en la politique
là ils ne croient plus à la société ils
ne croient plus à la nation parce qu'ils
sont isolés parce qu'il n'y a plus de
service public parce que les services
publics ont déserté nos territoires et
parce qu'enfin ils sont isolés de
l'emploi voilà la réalité la proximité
est indispensable elle était
indispensable aussi pour mettre en avant
le professionnalisme des fonctionnaires
territoriaux qui joue un rôle essentiel
de lien entre eux et les élus et les
territoires et puis évidemment sur la
clarté mais le premier ministre a
rassuré tout à l'heure c'est qu'il nous
propose c'est beaucoup de clarté et
enfin de l'efficacité alors mes chers
collègues mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je pense que nous pouvons nous
retrouver peut-être nous retrouver sur
un socle territoriales comme si nous
regardons le texte est pas le contexte
bien sûr nous avons des débats
politiques bien sûr que nous pouvons
nous opposer sur plein de sujets mais ce
socle territorial commun que notre goût
vous propose il est assez clair
tout d'abord constitué de grandes
régions de grandes régions stratège de
grandes régions qui innovent de viande
région qui oriente avec des schémas avec
évidemment les fonds européens c'est
déjà le cas mais enfin l'économie
l'économie ça doit être la compétence
essentielle des régions ces grandes
régions tout à l'heure bruno retailleau
a dit qu'il voulait bien avancé françois
zocchetto si nous verrons les compétents
je vais venir mais sur les grandes
régions le rapport raffarin
krattinger le disait déjà nous avons
besoin de grandes régions et nous
pouvons nous entendre c'est pas un
problème de féodaux sur un coin de table
c'est tout simplement avoir dessiné une
nouvelle carte des régions dont on parle
depuis 20 ans que personne n'a eu ni le
courage de faire n'y osé le faire et que
ce gouvernement est que le parlement va
enfin réaliser voilà une réforme en
profondeur et une réforme structurelle
il faut évidemment renforcé les
intercommunalités et là nous sommes
toutes et tous d'accord et le premier
ministre l'a évoquée il faut donner des
objectifs le premier objectif qui était
donné sur les intercommunalités c'était
dans la loi sarkozy fillion et on se
rappelle ce qui s'est passé dans les cdi
et les préfets en force voulant faire
rentrer les communes dans les intercoms
on a vu ce qui s'était passé et le
gouvernement dans son premier texte a
donné le chiffre de vingt mille et je
suis très heureux que le premier
ministre est entendu l'ensemble de la
représentation nationale parce que ce
chiffre de 20 milles ce chiffre de 20
mille n'est pas pour nous acceptable et
nous travaillerons avec d'autres mais il
s'agit pas ni d'en rire ni de faire des
remarques nous pensons nous pensons que
dans certains endroits il faudra des
grande interco a beaucoup plus de 20000
est beaucoup plus de 100000 mai en zone
rurale en zone de montagne en zone
périphérique il fera des plus petites
intercommunalités qui soient des bassins
de vie là dessus mes chers collègues
nous pouvons nous retrouver
et puis évidemment il faut affirmer le
rôle indispensable des communes le rôle
indispensable des communes et toutes ces
communes c'est notre richesse et en même
temps ça a été évoqué récemment par
l'association des maires de france il
faut aussi si elle le souhaite inciter
les communes à se regrouper à mutualiser
parce qu'il est tellement de petites
communes que les choses peuvent avancer
pas de façon imposé mais de façon
volontaire et bien là déjà nous nous
retrouvons enfin entre les deux entre
ces grandes régions et entre les
communes et les intercomités premier
ministre l'a évoqué il faut des conseils
départementaux qui joue ce rôle de
proximité seront à la fois de solidarité
territoriale et de solidarité humaine et
je remercie le premier ministre d'avoir
fait cette avancée parce que pour nous
elle est indispensable
le maintien des conseils départementaux
dans nos zones territoriales rural est
indispensable peut-être même peut-être
même d'ailleurs dans les départements
plus grand à condition de clarifier les
compétences et à condition que les
conseils départementaux ne fasse pas
tout comme ils le font aujourd'hui
parce que si j'étais le cas alors nous
serions au bout d'un système tu te qui
ne pourraient pas fonctionner clarifions
les choses solidarité urbaine solidarité
humaine solidarité territoriale oui les
conseils départementaux
dansez dansez dansez pas du tout dans
ces territoires est indispensable parce
que nous voulons garder non parce que
nous voulons garder à la fois des
conseillers régionaux et des conseillers
départementaux
nous ne sommes pas nous ne sommes pas
ceux qui disent on il faut réduire le
nombre d'élus non il faut des élus
qu'ils soient respectés enfin avant
dernier point il faut redéfinir le rôle
de l'état déconcentré oui oui monsieur
le premier ministre vous l'avez évoqué
il faut que l'état fasse des efforts
encore aller plus loin dans la
déconcentration aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation aller plus loin dans le
transfert et vous l'avez dit monsieur le
premier ministre et nous en sommes
satisfaits parce que ce n'est pas
uniquement les collectivités locales et
les élus territoriaux qui doivent faire
des efforts il faut aussi que l'état en
face et enfin dernier point de ce socle
territorial commun que nous vous
proposons c'est celui de sécuriser les
fonctionnaires départementaux qui ont
été ballottés au gré des diverses
réformes du conseiller territorial
d'alors à la suppression des conseils
départementaux d'aujourd'hui à la
nouvelle formule qui sera présenté oui
comme élu départemental
je sais que les fonctionnaires
territoriaux s'inquiète et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans le socle
commun territoriale que nous vous
proposons nous pouvons être d'accord
pour sécuriser les fonctionnaires
territoriaux sur leur devenir
professionnel voilà mes chers collègues
mesdames messieurs si nous avançons
tranquillement tranquillement en faisant
fi de toutes les polémiques en faisant
fi de toute la politique politicienne
peut-être nous à nous accordant en nous
accordant pardon que tout n'a pas été
aussi bien fait que de noms que nous
aurions pu l'espérer peut-être aurions
pu éviter quelques atermoiements
quelques changements de cap mais enfin
ce n'est pas le premier gouvernement qui
agit de la sorte n'ayant n'ayant pas la
mémoire courte n'ayant pas la mémoire
courte alors monsieur le
monsieur le président du sénat vous avez
souhaité lors de votre élection que le
sénat soit respecté que les sénat soit
entendu que les sénat soit écoutée dans
sa conclusion le premier ministre a dit
si chacun joue son rôle le gouvernement
par le nom il y aura une chance pour que
la réforme puisse se mettre en place
c'est ce que les socialistes le groupe
socialiste et apparentés du sénat vous
propose c'est de nous retrouver sur
l'essentiel
celui qui va parler à nos concitoyens
sur la proximité aux élus pour les
rassurer aux fonctionnaires territoriaux
pour les encourager tout simplement en
disant des grandes régions des conseils
départementaux de proximité des communes
les intercommunaux et une clarification
des compétences
la redéfinition du rôle de l'état et
enfin privilégier
aider les fonctionnaires territoriaux à
reprendre le moral si nous faisons cela
mesdames et messieurs mes chers
collègues je pense que nous pouvons le
faire ensemble nous pouvons ne pas être
d'accord sur toutes les lignes du texte
de loi show tel ou tel découpage de
telle ou telle région je sais que nous
avons des différences mais sur le fond
ce qui compte c'est que pour que le
sénat soit respectée il faut que le
sénat avance dans le sens de la
modernité dans le sens de la réforme et
la réforme qui est proposée par le
premier ministre par le gouvernement
d'abord sur les régions ensuite sur la
nouvelle organisation du titre de notre
territoire républicain est quelque chose
de très important nous sommes tous des
républicains convaincus la france est
une et indivisible mais elle est diverse
alors oui défendant la république
française mais défendons la république
française décentralisée pour la force de
nos convictions la force de
décentralisation la force des élus pour
être en phase avec la population en
solidarité avec les citoyens et surtout
pour faire en sorte que demain nos
collectivités locales et les moyens de
se développer de travailler en réseau
dans l'intérêt de notre pays je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le président la parole
est maintenant un d'autres collègues
ronan dantec pour le groupe écologiste
la parole
allez-y
enfin
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
les écologistes défendent depuis
toujours un renforcement des compétences
des collectivités territoriales car nous
considérons que c'est bien au plus près
des citoyens et en s'adaptant aux
spécificités de chaque territoire que
nous sommes en capacité de développer au
mieux l'action publique le projet des
écologistes en la matière est connue et
nous sommes constants dans nos
propositions autour du renforcement du
couple région intercommunalité avec
évidemment un suffrage universel direct
pour les conseillers communautaires en
charge des grandes politiques de la vie
quotidienne
tout nouveau projet de loi renforçant
les compétences des élus locaux et
régionaux
permettant une plus grande lisibilité de
l'action publique territoriale nous
semble donc aller dans le bon sens et
nous sommes prêts à le soutenir nous
avons donc applaudi monsieur le premier
ministre à une bonne part de vos
annonces en avril dernier
sur ce nécessaire engagement d'un
processus fort et rapide pour redessiner
les contours de l'action publique
territoriale la rendre plus cohérente
avec comme symbole de cette volonté de
faire simple et efficace l' annonce de
la suppression du département vieille
revendication des écologistes le projet
pouvait paraître audacieux vous sembliez
prêt à bousculer tous les conservatismes
et nous nous apprêtions déjà investir
nos modestes fort sénatoriale à vos
côtés pour vous aider dans la bataille
difficile qui s'annonce est dans cet
hémicycle face à tous les conservatismes
que bousculé déjà votre volontarisme
affiché aujourd'hui monsieur le premier
ministre nous répondons présents mais
nous sommes quand même un peu désorienté
avouons le où est en effet le champ de
bataille où est la ligne de front
les lignes ont tellement bougé depuis
six mois les alliances sont scellées
dénouer recomposée et plus personne ne
s'y retrouve vraiment et je n'ose même
pas évoqué le besoin d'une boussole
indiquant le nord car mes propos pour
être lue comme une prise de position sur
l'avenir le redécoupage des régions
septentrionales de notre pays il y a un
problème de méthode et reconnaissant
donc l'intérêt de ce débat
aujourd'hui pour essayer d'y voir plus
clair
j'insiste tout d'abord ça a été fait
avant moi sur lors de présentation des
projets de loi si on peut quand même
comprendre ne soyons pas caricaturaux
quelques urgence par rapport aux
contraintes constitutionnelles du
calendrier électoral
il n'en paraît pas moins évident qu
annoncé un aussi vaste heureux découpage
des régions françaises avant d'avoir
présidé préciser les compétences n'a
guère contribué à la clarté du débat
si je prends l'exemple que je connais le
mieux celui du redécoupage de l'ouest
peut-être que le statu quo qu'on
soutenait plus par calculs électoraux de
court terme et patriotisme
d'organisation que par vision d'avenir
nombre de grands élus des deux régions
n'aurait pas résisté à la prise de
conscience collectif des nouvelles
logiques de planification qui sont
inscrits dans la future loi que
présentera marylise lebranchu on peut
s'interroger est ce que les élus
régionaux de ces deux régions
administratives bretagne et pays de la
loire auraient pu continuer à soutenir
un statu quo indéfendable sur le fond
s'il avait fallu expliquer aux citoyens
que nous aurions ainsi demain un schéma
prescripteurs régional d'aménagement du
territoire qui ne chapeauterait même pas
l' axe majeur d'aménagement de l'ouest
et l'axé rennes-nantes qui va se
retrouver tronçonné entre deux schémas
prescriptif différents l'incohérence
devait alors sauté aux yeux et
l'immobilisme qui a trouvé dans l'ouest
en deux défenseurs dans les deux régions
sens aurait peut-être trouvé ébranlé
j'en viens donc aussi à la question qui
va nous occuper pendant deux ou trois
jours celle de la bonne carte pour la
france du xxième siècle je crois
monsieur le premier ministre à avoir
compris votre logique une france
reconstruite autour de grandes aires
urbaines censée entraîner l'ensemble de
leur territoire une grande région pour
bordeaux toulouse lyon marseille ou lire
une armature urbaine pour la normandie
ou l'est de la france ça se peut se
comprendre se défendre même si la
démonstration aurait gagne en clarté si
vous nous aviez expliqué précisément
comment la richesse sera distribuera
entre toulouse et fois entre lyon et
aurillac l'absence de définition des
mécanismes de solidarité territoriale un
terme autour de ces grandes régions nuit
probablement à la démonstration est
réduit l'adhésion à cette réforme de la
part de territoire se sentant
aujourd'hui faible et centrer mais nous
avons encore le temps dire travailler
dans le discussion de la loi le grand
sud sur ces mécanismes de solidarité
c'est un des socles d'une réforme
réussie cette réforme va également de
sens que dans la construction d'un
vouloir vivre ensemble clairement
exprimé plus de deux siècles après la
création des départements soixante ans
après les circonscriptions d'action
régional quelle grande opportunité que
la création d'une nouvelle carte à
l'image de la france d'aujourd'hui
malheureusement ici monsieur le premier
ministre vous avez refusé d'aller au
bout de la logique que vous aviez
pourtant initié en limitant la réforme à
l'alternative fusion de régions où statu
quo vous avez raté l'occasion d'une
carte partager comprise est largement
défendu ce débat passionne pourtant les
territoires a mis des dizaines de
milliers de personnes dans les rues à
nantua strasbourg fait la une des
journaux régionaux pourquoi ne pas avoir
organisé de grands débats publics avec
vote des assemblées concernées autour de
différents scénarios voir des
consultations populaires là où il n'y
avait pas consensus c'était un débat
désirer dans nos territoires il y a
aujourd'hui beaucoup de frustration dans
nombre de territoires de l'avoir occulté
monsieur le premier ministre mais
pourquoi donc ce refus de renforcer la
parole citoyenne d'intégrer la vie des
habitants permettent des initiatives
citoyennes ce n'est pas la chienlit ou
la boîte de pandore comme je les ai
entendus c'est au contraire conforté le
citoyen dans sa capacité d'intervention
dans le débat public c'est conforter la
démocratie locale et nationale nous
savons tous aujourd'hui combien il faut
d'urgence relégitimer le citoyen au
coeur du débat politique pour ne pas le
laisser aux désespérance entre
abstention et vote extrême et l'absence
l'exemple de l'alsace est ici centrale
sur l'alsace les choses sont extrêmement
claires les élus régionaux les élus
départementaux les habitants de manière
majoritaire se sont tous prononcés pour
une collectivité unique c'est
aujourd'hui sur la table le sénat le
soutien monsieur le premier ministre si
jamais vous revenez sur ce qui a été
clairement exprimée vous aller contre ce
que vous nous avez dit tout à l'heure de
d'avoir une organisation territoriale
qui correspond à une france diverse et
je crois que pour nous groupes
écologistes nous serons extrêmement
attentifs sur la ville nous porterons
sur la fin du processus sur la réponse
qui sera faite aux alsaciens et nous
soutenons évidemment ce projet de
collectivité territoriale unique
d'alsace
plus généralement à l'échelle des
départements pourquoi diable refuser le
droit d'option souplesse nécessaire à la
cohérence d'ensemble le sénat en
première lecture avait facilité ce droit
d'option l'assemblée nationale avec le
soutien du gouvernement la supprimer
nous le regrettons profondément ce
besoin de souplesse au service d'une
carte partager des passes et pourtant
les clivages politiques habituels
nous n'étions pas très loin d'un
consensus et je vous dis ici au nom du
groupe écologiste notre incompréhension
de la position gouvernementale sur le
fond comme sur la capacité de respecter
les travaux du sénat quand le sénat
exprime lui-même sa volonté de trouver
des consensus plus globalement sur le
rôle du département vous savez que des
écologistes ont toujours plaidé pour un
renforcement de la région allant donc de
pair avec la réduction des compétences
départementales
je lui dit en introduction c'est là le
sens de la loi en tout cas c'était dans
le préambule de la loi que marylise
lebranchu nous devait nous présenter
nous étions dans cette perspective
claire de la disparition du département
depuis lors l'histoire c'est un peu
complexifié et la disparition de
l'échelon départemental n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour cette évolution dans le
discours a été un peu caricaturée
parfois réduite à un accord avec un
groupe de la majorité voire un accord un
peu politicien je veux dire ici que nous
rejoignons aujourd'hui en partie ses
conclusions sur l'avenir du département
autant les départements n'avait pas de
sens dans de petites régions autant leur
maintien comme échelon entre petites
intercommunalités et grande région avec
les compétences principalement de
l'action sociale fait sens pour avoir
comme d'autres échangé avec nombre
d'élus d'intercommunalité de mon
département je peux aussi témoigner de
leur refus de se voir confier les
compétences sociales et donc leur
volonté de maintien des échelons
départemental sur ce point je crois que
le débat a fait évoluer les visions y
compris chez les sénateurs écologistes
mais pour autant ne faut-il pas faire
évoluer ce département je vous propose
monsieur le premier ministre un slogan
simple moine région - département c'est
simple et lisible je prends toujours
l'exemple de lax nombre n 1 département
unique de haute bretagne entre nantes et
rennes avec des problématiques
territoriales qui sont exactement les
mêmes pour l'ensemble des territoires
contre les deux grandes métropoles c'est
le sens de l'histoire et pour cete le
président mézard fait plus confiance à
l'intelligence territoriale dans ce
cadre-là
sur l'avenir du département
reposons-nous demain alors je sais que
ça ne passera pas ici tout de suite la
question du bicamérisme est ce que
demain ces grandes régions avec des
compétences forts doivent être géré
uniquement par un scrutin proportionnel
au suffrage direct ou est-ce que deux
chambres avec une chambre plus issus des
territoires ne permettrait pas un
meilleur équilibre et répondre à un
certain nombre d'inquiétudes qui se sont
exprimés dans le débat je pense que
c'est une piste à explorer c'est une
piste qui existe ailleurs en europe elle
n'est absolument pas un exogènes au
débat de même mais nous n'aurons pas
temps d'y revenir ce soir la question du
statut de l'élu local est une question
clé de cette réforme les élus locaux ont
aujourd'hui un rôle fondamental dans le
maintien de la cohésion sociale et
territoriale dans ce pays il faudra
revenir sur le statut de l'élu local il
faudra de nouveau le renforcer et il
faudra et ça a été dit juste avant moi
rassurer les fonctionnaires territoriaux
qui s'inquiète beaucoup pour leur avenir
qu'ils ont effectivement l'impression
d'être aujourd'hui ballotté au gré des
débats ils sont eux aussi des acteurs
clés de la cohésion de nos territoires
monsieur le premier ministre
nous avons donc aujourd'hui énormément
d'interrogations sur cette réforme c'est
une réforme au milieu du gué dans le
brouillard de ses compétences nouvelles
mal définis permettront-elles le
maintien de la cohésion territoriale ou
son renforcement dans l'inconnu et ça a
été dit de la place de l'état demain
dans cette nouvelle architecture dans l'
angoisse aussi d'élus locaux craignant
de perdre pied par manque de moyens
financiers et bien dans ce brouillard
nous avons effectivement un peu de mal à
percevoir l'autre rive pour dissiper ce
brouillard il faut aujourd'hui un
souffle décentralisateur bien plus fort
nous sentons bien quelques brises
agréable mais toujours aussi bien légère
monsieur le premier ministre pour
franchir la rivière un bond est
préférable à une étape surtout au milieu
du gué le groupe écologie soutiendra une
réforme ambitieuse et lisible mais pas
une réforme qui resterait au milieu de
la rivière je vous remercie
merci à notre collègue la parole est
maintenant un madame la présidente
eliane assassi pour le groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
merci d'abord au président larcher pour
votre initiative et merci à monsieur le
premier ministre d'être parmi nous cet
après-midi pour clarifier cette réforme
territoriale avant toute chose quitte à
empiéter sur mon temps de parole
permettez moi de vous faire part de
l'émotion de mon groupe après le décès
dans des conditions qui restent encore à
déterminer du jeune rémi fraysse qui
manie fils qui manifestaient pour la
suspension des travaux du barrage si
dense dans l'eau dans le tarn on ne peut
pas mourir à 21 ans nos pensées sont
tournées vers sa famille ses proches et
nous espérons que la lumière sur ce
drame sera faite au plus vite mes chers
collègues notre débat de cet après midi
ne peut pas à notre avis être déconnecté
de ce qui se passe dans le pays chômage
en constante progression croissance
quasi-nulle demande agonisante et
l'austérité bien présente alors que les
déficits sont à leur paroxysme
de manière générale et principalement
dans ces circonstances vous n'êtes pas
sans savoir que les élus les
collectivités sont souvent les derniers
remparts certains disaient bouclier
contre la dislocation du tissu social
monsieur le premier ministre en quelque
sorte avec votre déclaration
d'aujourd'hui sur la réforme
territoriale
vous nous présenter à nouveau votre
projet de société
libérale sociale libérale je vous laisse
le soin de le qualifier pour ma part ce
qui m'intéresse ce sont les contenus et
c'est le sens mais une chose est sûre ce
projet tourne le dos aux valeurs qui ont
construit la gauche au fil des décennies
peu sont celles et ceux qui croient
aujourd'hui que l'objectif de votre
politique est de répondre aux espoirs de
mai 2012 d'ailleurs vous ne cessez vous
même de le répéter vous voulez casser le
lien avec cette gauche que vous avez
renier alors qu'elle fonde pourtant
votre seule légitimité politique votre
gouvernement a entériné une politique de
l'offre conforme aux souhaits du medef
et pour la financer vous vous attaquez à
notre protection sociale à notre code du
travail et à nos collectivités
en résumé vous demander des efforts à la
population pour améliorer la situation
du pays alors que vous faites des
cadeaux aux entreprises et à leurs
actionnaires
autant de choix qui n'offrent pas de
différence de fond avec la politique
économique menée par la droite entre
deux mots vous ne laisser qu'un seul
choix aux français
celui de choisir entre le moins pire
soit la réduction de 50 milliards que
vous proposez soit le pire avec une
réduction de 120 milliards voulue par la
droite mais pire ou moins pire c'est
toujours piliers et ce n'est ni pour
l'un ni pour l'autre que nous avons voté
certes vous n'êtes pas monsieur le
premier ministre je dois reconnaître le
seul responsable des évolutions libéral
en matière économique et social de la
société il en est de même pour le sujet
qui nous occupe aujourd'hui
l'organisation du territoire cette
évolution remontent à de longues années
après les grands espoirs suscités par
les lois de décentralisation de 80 de la
loi constitutionnelle du 28 mars 2003
fut celle qui a amorcé le morcellement
de la république le premier ministre de
l'époque notre collègue monsieur
raffarin
en avait fait sa réforme clé la clé
d'une politique libérale totalement
revendiqués dont l'objectif a été dopée
ray de vastes transfert d'activités
publiques rentables vers le secteur
privé et de diminuer considérablement
les dépenses publiques les réformes
engagées par nicolas sakozy ont
poursuivi une logique du désengagement
financier politique de l'état avec une
méthode celle de la mise en compétition
à la libérale des territoires mortifère
pour les communes la réforme des
collectivités territoriales de 2010 que
pourtant toute la gauche avait combattu
n'a été ni un projet ni détricoté par
votre gouvernement seul le conseiller
territorial qui remplaçait les
conseillers généraux et régionaux a été
supprimée par l'adoption d'une ppl
déposée par notre groupe au sénat
réformer nos territoires pour réformer
la france voilà la formule utilisée par
le président de la république pour
justifier sa politique territoriale qui
remet en cause architecture
institutionnelle de notre pays cette
réforme territoriale vise trois
objectifs
imposer l'austérité
attisé la concurrence entre les
territoires et ouvrir de nouveaux
espaces de profits pour les marchés tout
en détruisant la démocratie locale
précipité cette réforme qui plus est
sans consulter le peuple est le symptôme
de la poursuite des attaques portées
contre la république dénotant un vrai
mépris pour la démocratie et la
souveraineté populaire en se pliant à la
seule volonté de la commission
européenne dont l'ambition est de
dissoudre en promouvant les régions le
cadre national pour faciliter la
circulation des capitaux et des
travailleurs sans droits
scindés en plusieurs textes cette
réforme est devenue illisible quoi qu'en
disent certains pour nos concitoyens
comment peuvent-ils s'y retrouver quand
les élus locaux eux même s'ils perdent
en fait elle s'attaque aux deux
collectivités les plus proches des
citoyens
celles qui sont à leurs côtés dans leurs
difficultés cela ne peut donc que
renforcer la crise politique et donc qu
engendrer une remise en cause de la
cohésion sociale
répondant aux attentes de la commission
européenne et du top secret comité des
régions la suppression des départements
et la réorganisation libéral du
territoire marque la volonté de réduire
à son maximum l'expression de la
souveraineté populaire en ce sens
l'adaptation du territoire au
libéralisme sacrifie les structures
démocratiques pour mieux s'éloigner de
l'intérêt général
par ailleurs ce projet porte une
conception recentrer sur ses missions
une conception de l'état recentrer sur
ses missions régaliennes telle qu elle
est promue par les idéologues du
libéralisme et leur traité européen afin
de réduire les dépenses publiques cet
aménagement du territoire entraînera
nécessairement une mise en concurrence
internationale européennes et nationales
des territoires elle aura pour
conséquence prévisible d'approfondir le
fos le fossé entre les régions à fort
potentiel économique et les autres les
raisons riches ne vont certainement pas
tiré les régions les plus pauvres elles
vont en réalité
être un véritable trou noir qui aspirera
l'essentiel des richesses cette
concurrence induira un déséquilibre
territorial une hiérarchie inévitable et
laissera encore davantage les plus
démunis au bord de la route
mettre en concurrence des territoires
participent du démantèlement des
services publics garants du principe
d'égalité
de ce point de vue ce qui nous sépare
profondément c'est notre attachement aux
principes républicains
d'unicité des services publics or c'est
très pop cette réforme porte dans ses
fondements même l'éclatement de
l'égalité républicaine
cette mise en concurrence a d'ailleurs
été poussée à son paroxysme avec la
création des métropoles ces dernières
dans un objectif de concentration et
d'optimisation économique créé de grands
centres économiques adaptées au marché
et met à la disposition des
multinationales et du marché capitaliste
un espace dans lequel il va pouvoir
trouver tout ce dont il a besoin pour
satisfaire ses appétits
en clair tout est fait pour mettre les
institutions au service des dogmes de
rentabilité de compétitivité nous
n'acceptons pas monsieur le premier
ministre votre gouvernement qui tient sa
légitimité du peuple de gauche avance et
répète comme un vieux disque rayé ce
fameux argument de la réduction des
dépenses publiques le regroupement et la
mutualisation permettrait selon vous de
faire des économies sans licenciement
tout en améliorant les prestations à la
population
alors je dois dire que qui à part vous
et vos amis bien évidemment peut
sincèrement soutenir cette thèse
beaucoup considèrent aujourd'hui
y compris des agences de notation c'est
un comble donc beaucoup considèrent que
les frais de regroupement des
organisations nouvelles vont coûter plus
cher pendant cinq à dix ans ce ne sont
pas les frais de structure ni les
fonctions supports qui coûte le plus
dans nos collectivités territoriales
mais les services mis en place en faveur
de la population
il n'y aura un oeil au règne aura
réduction des coûts qu'au prix bien
évidemment d'une règle d'une réduction
brutale des services ce qui est bien
l'objectif inavoué de cette réforme si
les collectivités dépensent pour se
réorganiser et que dans le même temps
les dotations de l'état baissent alors
les collectivités devront réduire leurs
actions en direction de la population
ainsi que leurs investissements mais ce
mouvement est déjà à l'oeuvre et
l'austérité gagnera toujours plus
l'action locale comment pouvez vous
ignorer monsieur le ministre à ce point
la colère qui monte chez les élus chez
les fonctionnaires chez nos concitoyens
face à la réduction des dotations aux
collectivités cet après midi même
de nombreux maires ruraux sont venus
dire cette colère devant le sénat
monsieur le ministre monsieur le premier
ministre votre vision la démocratie de
l'organisation des institutions et du
territoire enfin notre vision de la
démocratie plutôt many archaïque ni
dépasser c'est la politique du
gouvernement qui n'est nullement tourner
vers l'avenir et qui s'inspire des vieux
précepte libéraux à peine dépoussiérer
des économistes des 10 8e et des dix
neuvième siècle david ricardo et adam si
c'est votre politique qui ramène vers le
passé notre pays retour sur les acquis
sociaux au travers du plfss pour 2015
destruction organisée des services
publics
culpabilisation des chômeurs atteinte
aux droits des salariés coups donnés aux
fonctionnaires recentralisation des
pouvoirs
éloignement des centres de décisions des
citoyens et j'en passe
sous couvert de modernité c'est en
réalité un recul démocratique majeur qui
est en cours non monsieur le premier
ministre pour reprendre vos propos beau
terme dans une cave ue a accordé un des
deux valeurs qui a changé de nom nous ne
choisissons pas comme vous le dites de
défendre les solutions d'hier plutôt que
de résoudre les problèmes d'aujourd'hui
nous sommes des partisans déterminés du
progrès et le progrès selon nous c'est
placer l'humain au coeur des décisions
et non la logique financière et
comptable comme vous le faites vous nous
sommes favorables à une évolution des
structures locales encore faut-il
analyser les forces et les faiblesses de
ce qui existe aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi
nous proposons dans le respect des
structures démocratiques existence de
remettre à plat notre organisation
territoriale
accompagné d'une réforme fiscale
renforçant vous savez cette fameuse
réforme fiscale dont nous avons
longtemps attendu par les pies qui a été
enterrée donc accompagné d'une réforme
fiscale renforçant la libre
administration des collectivités et les
outils de péréquation sur la base de
quatre axes cadre de nos démocraties
proximité coopération service public
nous sommes pour une profonde rénovation
de nos institutions
rénovation tourner vers le partage et
non la domination d une sur des autres
dès lors que ce sont les objectifs de
service public et d'épanouissement
humain qui prime nous sommes monsieur le
premier ministre favorable à des
regroupements de territoire dès lors
également qu'ils se font sur la base de
projets convergents respectueux de
l'unicité de la république quant à
l'état nous voulons qu'ils
s'investissent dans de grands projets
structurants utile
développeur de solutions publics
créateurs d'emplois et qui joue son rôle
à son échelle dans un certain nombre de
domaines santé transports éducation
énergie culture environnement etc oui
nous sommes monsieur le premier ministre
pour une sixième république démocratique
et sociale et je dois vous dire que nous
sommes courageux nous n'avons pas peur
et vous savez bien de changer
radicalement nos institutions à
condition qu'elles apportent plus de
démocratie je pense à l'assemblée
constituante plus d'implication
citoyenne je pense au contrôle citoyen
par un droit de regard sur les prises de
décision et par plus de coopération
monsieur le premier ministre votre
réforme celle du président n'est pas
majoritaire chez les élus et dans le
pays elle est même à l'origine de
fissures au sein de votre majorité elle
doit faire l'objet d'un référendum
populaire car le peuple ne peut être mis
devant le fait accompli d'une telle
modification des règles démocratiques
contrairement aux idées reçues nos
concitoyens sont très attachés à leur
collectivité dont leurs départements y
compris en milieu urbain comme en
témoignent les trente-deux mille
signatures recueillies dans le bal de
mam que mon ami christian favier
sénateur et président du conseil général
va vous remettre aujourd'hui oui
monsieur le premier ministre
l'heure est au choix entre les valeurs
d'avenir de progrès de justice sociale
de gauche en résumé de cette gauche dont
la raison d'être est la contestation de
la toute puissance du capitalisme est
celle d'un libéralisme passé in east a
que goûter sur ses privilèges dont vous
semblez malheureusement vous faire
aujourd'hui le porte-parole
merci madame la présidente la parole et
matin au président philippe bas
sans fard
le jeu
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre et mes chers collègues
sur le premier ministre vous avez
revendiqué
al'avantage de votre réforme la clarté
la simplicité la lisibilité
j'ai compris le modèle auquel vous
voulez vous rattachez
car si votre réforme n'est pas marquée
par ses qualités de lisibilité que vous
revendiquez votre discours était clair
vous avez un modèle
ce modèle la réalité de votre réforme ne
correspond pas vous ne l'assumé pas vous
même et de toute façon qui ne correspond
pas au modèle que nous avons à l'esprit
et j'espère que ce débat puis la
discussion de vos textes permettront de
rapprocher les points de vue mais force
est de reconnaître
qu'il y a tout de même beaucoup de
chemin à faire
votre modèle
l'état vous n'en parlez pas
les régions voulait qualifié de grande
région stratège
des départements vous avez annoncé leur
suppression je sais bien qu'après des
discussions
des évolutions des atermoiements ont eu
lieu qui nous rendent très incertain de
l'avenir mais enfin dans la clarté de
votre propos et 2 du propos du
gouvernement c'est la suppression des
départements à venir
les intercommunalités les métropoles
vous voulez les renforcer les communes
et communes vous les oubliez
ça c'est votre modèle
ce modèle ce modèle vous ne l'assumé pas
vous ne l'assumé pas
l'état
cet état absent de votre discours c'est
un état qui asphyxie les collectivités
territoriales c'est un état qui
aggravent leurs charges et l'exemple que
vous avez malencontreusement cité
des rythmes scolaires
en attestent
je suis le modeste vice président d'une
communauté de communes de 16 mille
habitants nous avons mille élèves dans
l'enseignement primaire
comme nous sommes bons citoyens nous
accueillons les enfants pour des
activités périscolaires cela nous coûte
l'équivalent de huit et demi pour cent
de nos ressources fiscales
l'état asphyxie les collectivités
territoriales
les régions
mais monsieur le premier ministre
vos régions vos régions stratège vont
être des régions ankylosé
enlisé dans la gestion du quotidien des
régions obèses sans dynamisme sans
ressort pour le développement économique
et l'animation des territoires car vous
les avez lourdement lestées dans votre
projet de réforme de compétences de
proximité qui était fort bien exercée
par les départements mais comme vous ne
savez que faire des départements vous
avez pensé à droit de transférer ses
compétences aux régions ça ne correspond
pas du tout aux modèles que vous
décrivez
les départements les départements vous
ne les supprimez pas
non vous les supprimez pas ni tout de
suite ni demain car vous ne serez plus
là en 2020 et par conséquent ce que vous
dites des départements aujourd'hui c'est
seulement pour en parler
vous postulez pour compte d'autrui il
n'y a rien dans votre réforme sur
l'avenir des départements parce que vous
avez peur
d'affronter une révision
constitutionnelle et vous avez peur
d'affronter le peuple français si vous
devez soumettre cette révision
constitutionnelle au référendum c'est la
raison pour laquelle est la seule c'est
la raison pour laquelle vous avez reculé
sur la suppression des départements ce
qui ne vous empêche pas de faire de
multiples concessions au fil des
semaines des concessions qui ne vous
engage à rien encore une fois car ce
n'est pas qui aurait à décider de
l'avenir des départements j'en suis
convaincu je ne veux pas non plus
anticipé sur ce que les français
décideront dans quelques années ce
serait tout à fait prématuré et se
serait en effet manquer de modestie de
ma part c'est la raison pour laquelle je
n'irai pas sur ce terrain là mais il est
probable de toute façon qu'il y aura une
élection présidentielle en 2017 et un
nouveau gouvernement nous verrons bien
ce qu'il voudra faire de l'avenir des
départements mais pour l'heure pour
l'heure vous handicaper fortement
l'avenir de ces départements en leur
retirant des compétences qu'ils exercent
pourtant mieux que nous pourrons le
faire les régions les intercommunalités
voulait déstabiliser profondément
la plupart des nouvelles
intercommunalités se sont mises en place
en janvier leur nouveau conseil ont été
désignés en avril leur exécutif se sont
mis en place en avril et vous voudriez
déjà après plusieurs années de mise en
place de ces intercommunalités les
bousculer les renverser les disloquer
pour les regrouper dans des ensembles
plus vastes vous avez fixé ce seuil de
20 mille habitants vous vous êtes rendu
compte et je vous en remercie qu'il y
avait quelque chose d'excessif dans
l'application obligatoire de cette règle
abrupte en mieux les choses évoluent ça
prouve que une évolution positive peut
être réalisée n'empêche que remettent le
couvert après un exercice si difficile
et si tôt alors que la loi prévoit elle
même une clause de rendez-vous après
quelques années d'expérience qui aurait
permis à nos intercommunalités de
reprendre souffle ça me parait ça nous
paraît une mauvaise idée et puis pour
les communes les communes les grandes
oubliées de la réforme pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas réfléchi au
développement des communes nouvelles
pour que les communes qui le souhaitent
soit incité à se regrouper et soit plus
forte dans les intercommunalités et
puisse conserver des compétences de
proximité qu'elles n'ont pas forcément
en deux délégués aux intercommunalités
dans des décisions qui seront forcément
plus lointaines le premier ministre a
fait entre nous de grandes différences
pourront-elles être comblé
notre dialogue permettra peut-être
d'avancer dans cette voie en ce qui nous
concerne nous le souhaitons mais il
faudra pour cela que vous avez lanciers
plus franchement en choisissant la ligne
droite au lieu de contourner l'obstacle
et de prendre un chemin sinueux et
incertain les concessions vous avez
prétendu faire sur les départements
comme je le disais tout à l'heure sont
des confessions qui ne vous engage à
rien en revanche les concessions que
vous ne faites pas actuellement sur les
départements vous engagerez à quelque
chose et ce sont ces concessions là que
nous attendons et non pas des
concessions spéculative nous sommes en
ce qui nous concerne dans l'action et
non pas dans la doctrine pour savoir ce
que dans cinq ans l'on pourra faire vous
avez mis le département en voie
d'extinction est en apesanteur le
département est profondément déstabilisé
ces personnels sont démoralisés le
département est interdit de projet ils
n'avaient ce tir a plu car il est en
attente il est tétanisé par votre
réforme alors monsieur le premier
ministre au lieu au lieu d'insister
comme vous le faites
en agitant une sorte de rideau de fumée
sur l'avenir mortifère que vous vous
avez annoncé pour les départements vous
feriez mieux tout de suite de ne pas
handicaper les régions en les laisse
tant de compétences qui sont des
compétences en réalité de gestion de
maintenance et de proximité et laissé
aux départements l'exercice de ses
compétences en mettant un petit peu de
clarté dans la répartition des rôles oui
aux régions stratège que vous préconisez
mais pour qu'elle soit stratège il ne
faut pas que ces régions soient des
régions obèses oui aussi aux
départements qui ont un avenir que tout
à l'heure notre collègue mézard a
rappelé en vous citant vous même lorsque
vous étiez ministre de l'intérieur nous
n'avons pas raisonné renoncé à donner un
avenir au département car c'est pour
nous le meilleur service des citoyens de
notre pays
entre toutes les solutions possibles
toutes les solutions qui sont à votre
disposition
vous avez choisi la pire vous avez pris
le parti de l'antre 2 et ça ne peut pas
durer cinq ans monsieur le premier
ministre il faut en sortir il faut cette
clarté que vous avez voulu vous
approprier je ne nie pas que vous nous
avez tenu un discours clair mais ne
correspond pas à la réalité
vous êtes en train d'ailleurs de
concevoir de véritable usine à gaz
quand vous pensez à cet avenir qui ne
dépend pas que de jouer pour les
départements car vous avez bien imaginer
que
il faudra bien remplacer par quelque
chose les départements que vous voulez
faire disparaître alors on a tantôt
entendu parler d' agences régionales
dans les départements nous avons aussi
entendu par les deux fédérations
d'intercommunalité vous évoquez les
fusions de départements de métropole
vous maintenez les départements ruraux
oui mais lesquelles vous évoquez le rôle
des agences régionales de santé et des
caisses de sécurité sociale pour la
gestion des problèmes sociaux personne
ne s'y retrouve aujourd'hui le point
commun de toutes ces idées qui sont
agités aujourd'hui ce que vous voulez
faire disparaître un système
démocratique celui des conseils généraux
avec leurs élus au suffrage universel
direct pour remplacer ce système
démocratique par un système
technocratique je regrette de le dire
parce que c'est la vérité
quant aux régions
nous avons d'abord un désaccord profond
sur la méthode
honnêtement dessiner la carte des
régions
en dehors des heures de service
évidemment sur un coin de table
c'est pas une bonne idée le moindre
regroupements d'intercommunalités
passe par une procédure démocratique de
consultation de vote de nos
collectivités territoriales mais leur
poule et régions sans doute n'ont elles
pas dans votre esprit autant
d'importance que vous voulez bien le
dire le législateur est saisie temps
pour battant est sommé de participer à
vos choix à la hussarde
nous sommes dans un esprit coopératif
j'espère que vous l'entendez à travers
mes propos
cet esprit coopératif
nous conduit à examiner tout de même
cette carte
du moins inspirons-nous que vous
tiendrez compte de ce que nous avons à
vous dire sur ce sujet est ce que nous
avons à vous dire c'est aussi que nous
craignons nous même
de devoir prendre des décisions qui ne
serait pas assise sur une concertation
suffisante avec les élus et les forces
vives des territoires concernés et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est vital
dans des conditions de délai limité qui
existe un droit d'option et que ce coup
droit d'option puisse prendre corps
parce que si les forces démocratiques
régionales départementales de notre pays
souhaite des modifications des
frontières régionales que nous aurons
décidé par la loi il ne serait pas juste
de les en empêcher
il faut qu'il y ait une soupape de
sûreté dans ce système que vous avez
choisi sinon il va être trop brutale il
n'est pas certain que beaucoup de
départements auront envie d'utiliser
cette faculté mais il est tout
simplement impossible
irrespectueux de la démocratie locale de
ne pas la prévoir au moins et de ne pas
adopter un système de droits d'options
qui puisse réellement fonctionné
monsieur le premier ministre
nous aimerions pouvoir vous aider
nous craignons la voie
que vous avez choisi
vous prenez le risque
de rester comme l'inventeur
d'un nouveau
centralisme le centralisme régionales
plutôt le centralisme super régionale
puisque ce sont des supers région qu'il
s'agit de constituer ce centralisme en
cache un autre
mieux connue de tous le centralisme
d'état
je le vois dans votre réforme sur
l'organisation territoriale quand vous
donnez au préfet de région un véritable
pouvoir de tutelle puisqu'ils auront
approuvé avant qu'il rentre en vigueur
les grands schémas pour le développement
économique et pour
l'aménagement des du foncier qui sont
prévues par ce texte et puis
je le rappelle vous n'avez pas eu de
véritable réflexion jusqu'à ce jour
d'ailleurs sur le transfert de
compétences de l'état aux régions
alors il ya une phrase de votre propos
tout à l'heure qui a
apporté une musique moins désagréable
c'est cette idée que devant la carence
des politiques publiques de l'état en
matière d'emploi il pourrait être
intéressant de développer par transferts
de compétences de l'état
à côté des compétences de formation
professionnelle des régions des
compétences en matière de politique de
l'emploi et bien travaillée
retravaillons zee je crois que le sénat
est tout à fait intéressé par ce que
j'ai cru percevoir comme une ouverture
de votre part le premier mise face au
millefeuille administratif
territorial pour éliminer les doublons
vous préconisez la suppression d'un
échelon mais vous vous gardez bien de
mettre à exécution cette préconisation
nous proposons quant à nous un autre
modèle celui de la spéciale lisa sion
des échelons chacun doit exercer les
responsabilités les pouvoirs et les
compétences pour lesquelles il est le
mieux placé selon un principe que le
président jacques chirac et son premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin ont voulu
porter dans la constitution c'est la
révision constitutionnelle de 2003 ça
s'appelle le principe de subsidiarité
si vous évoluez dans cette idée de
principe de subsidiarité vous ne
trouverez naturellement à vos côtés nous
souhaitons être entendu pour que la
réforme territoriale soit une réforme
voilà pour cette après midi consacrée à
la réforme territoriale avec tout
d'abord la déclaration du gouvernement
qui a été suivi du débat des sénateurs à
leur bilan de cette après midi on a tout
d'abord pu entendre le premier ministre
manuel valls avec deux points marquants
dans son discours tout d'abord le
premier ministre est resté ferme sur la
carte des régions on a pu comprendre à
travers son allocution qu'il tenait à la
carte de france à 12 régions c'est à
dire la version qui était sorti des
travaux du gouvernement l'été dernier et
qu'il n'est pas favorable à ce qui est
sorti des travaux de la commission
spéciale du sénat la semaine dernière
commission spéciale qui a dessiné elle
une france avec 15 régions avec
notamment une alsace autonome et la
division entre les régions midi pyrénées
et languedoc roussillon
autre point marquant de ce discours est
bien le flou qui reste sur l'avenir des
départements vont ils disparaître d'ici
2020 et bien ici à nier les élus ni les
observateurs n'ont réellement compris ce
que voulait dire le premier ministre
après cela et bien on a pu très
clairement voir un hémicycle divisée en
deux avec d'une part l'ump
les centristes les radicaux de gauche le
groupe rds mais aussi les communistes
qui étaient tous des opposants à ce
texte et d'autre part le groupe
socialiste alors du côté de la droite on
a notamment très ardemment regretté la
division des de l'examen de ce texte
entre le contenant et le contenu avec la
division entre deux textes avec d'une
part les la carte des régions et les
compétences mais toutefois on a pu voir
que tous les sénateurs étaient d'accord
pour dire que le sénat avait un rôle à
jouer une véritable plus value qu'ils
voulaient tous mettre en avant cela
qu'ils soient de droite ou de gauche